le sens particulièrement difficile pour
nous informer
c'est aussi avec émotion que nous avons
appris la taille object perpétré à la
synagogue de la grippe à Djerba en
Tunisie qui a coûté la vie à 4 personnes
ont l'un de nos compatriotes Benjamin
Haddad
là encore je suis certain que nos
pensées vont vers les familles des
victimes et leurs proches
je vous remercie
donc merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs je
souhaite à mon tour au nom du
gouvernement exprimé toute mon émotion
et ma solidarité après le décès hier en
Ukraine du journaliste Harman soldier
qui couvrait le conflit pour l'AFP mes
premières pensées vont à sa famille et à
ses proches elles vont à ses collègues
de l'Agence France Presse elles vont à
tous les journalistes
Harman soldin accomplissé son métier sa
passion sa vocation il est tombé parce
qu'il voulait faire connaître des faits
il est tombé parce qu'il croyait que le
devoir d'informer ne doit reculer devant
rien
le journaliste la presse libre sont
essentielles pour nous concitoyens et
pour notre démocratie alors ici avec
vous à mon tour je veux rendre hommage à
Harman soldin et je voudrais également
exprimer toute mon toute mon émotion
après l'attentat en Tunisie et là encore
exprimer toute ma solidarité aux proches
des victimes je vous remercie
si madame la Première ministre pour ses
propos
l'ordre du jour appelle les questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement notre
science est retransmise en direct sur
Public Sénat sur notre site internet
chacun sera attentif au respect respect
des uns et des autres et respect du
temps de parole je donne la parole à
notre collègue Xavier yakovelli pour le
regroupe du rassemblement des démocrates
progressistes et indépendants vous avez
la parole merci monsieur le Président ma
question s'adresse à Madame la Ministre
chargée de l'enseignement et de la
formation professionnelle madame
ministre après la réforme de
l'apprentissage le président de la
République a affirmé récemment aux
Français son engagement de transformer
la voie professionnelle actuellement
dans notre pays un tiers des lycéens
sont en lycées professionnel parmi ces
620000 jeunes un tiers n'arrive pas
jusqu'au bac et pour ceux qui ont le bac
une proportion très importante n'entre
pas dans le marché du travail d'autres
se dirigent en études supérieur mais la
moitié d'entre eux ne décroche pas un
diplôme nous sommes donc face à une
situation
qui est loin d'être satisfaisante et
parallèlement il y a des métiers qui ont
du mal à recruter et qui ne trouvent
plus de jeunes la souveraineté
industrielle numérique comme énergétique
nécessite aussi de placer le lycée
professionnel au centre de nos enjeux de
formation et de repenser ainsi le
parcours des lycéens le lycée
professionnel doit donc redevenir un
choix pour la plupart des jeunes à la
recherche de métiers d'avenir et une
solution pour les entreprises qui
doivent s'adapter aux grandes
transitions économiques en cours et à
venir
en faisant évoluer l'offre de formation
proposée par les lycées c'est ainsi que
nous redonnerons du sens à la valeur
travail et prépareront les compétences
de demain en adéquation bien sûr avec
les aspirations des jeunes de leur temps
et du monde dans lequel ils vivent nos
territoires avec leur spécificités et
leur bassins d'emploi doivent également
être associés au cœur de cette réforme
je pense notamment à la révision de la
carte des formations qui devrait être
qui devrait aller dans ce sens c'est là
aussi une question d'égalité des chances
il est donc temps de faire du lycée
professionnel avant d'être une filière
d'excellence une vraie filière d'avenir
aussi madame aministre ma question est
les quels sont les intentions du
Gouvernement pardon concernant la
réforme de la carte de formation au vu
des enjeux économiques de demain mais
aussi au vu des spécificités qui
caractérisent nos territoires je vous
remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué chargé de
l'enseignement et de la formation
professionnelle madame Grandjean
monsieur le président
les sénateurs monsieur le sénateur
yakovelli votre attachement à ce que le
lycée professionnel soit une voix de
choix une voix de réussite pour tous
aussi bien sûr pour les élèves mais
aussi offre des conditions de travail
pour les enseignants et prépare les
compétences du pays et tout le sens de
la réforme du lycée professionnel que le
Président de la République a présenté la
semaine dernière nous allons pour cela
lutter contre le décrochage et
accompagner les fragilités de ses élèves
pour qu'ils réussissent mieux dans leur
parcours scolaire nous allons également
favoriser leur insertion professionnelle
et leur poursuite d'études réussites
ainsi que de valoriser ces filières
stratégiques pour tout le pays c'est un
changement au fond d'image que nous
souhaitons pouvoir réaliser pour la voie
professionnelle elle est à notre portée
si effectivement nous donnons les
conditions de réussite évoquées si ces
jeunes réussissent et si ces filières
ouvrent de vraies perspectives à cette
jeunesse nous allons donc ouvrir de
nouvelles formations monsieur le
sénateur des formations revenir avec des
augmentations du nombre de places dans
certaines filières notamment celle
relatives à l'énergie à l'écologie au
numérique mais aussi aux soins qui sont
des filières sur lesquels l'avenir est
ouvert à ces jeunes et puis fermé des
formations dont les taux d'insertion ne
sont pas satisfaisants ni le taux de
poursuite d'études réussites il faut que
nous prennent le lycée professionnel
comme une filière de réussite une
filière stratégique pour la préparation
des compétences de la nation et chaque
territoire est spécifique bien sûr mais
lorsqu'on regarde les 10 premières les
10 premiers métiers qui sont recherchés
au fond les 7 sont au moins
correspondants dans l'ensemble des
territoires notamment ceux que
j'évoquais tout de suite nous allons
faire un investissement inédit pour
accompagner cette évolution de la carte
des formations nous allons au-delà du
milliards d'euros supplémentaires par an
apporter au lycée professionnel pour
travailler sur la pédagogie nous allons
également investir via France 2030 sur
les plateaux techniques avec les régions
pour améliorer le plateau technique
former des professeurs travailler sur
l'attractivité de ces filières et
organiser une dynamique pour ses lycées
professionnels je vous remercie merci
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur nous avons été
choqués que vous ayez laissé se dérouler
une manifestation non loin d'ici en
plein Paris à la veille de la
commémoration de la Libération
du jongle nazi en Europe avec des
organisateurs et des participants dont
des proches de Marine Le Pen qui
menaçaient des journalistes des badauds
qui se réclament de l'idéologie nazie et
pétainiste qui appelle à abattre la
République et qui appelle explicitement
à la haine raciste et antisémite nous
avons été en Suisse stupéfait que le
préfet de police que des ministres la
première d'entre elles et puis justifier
se laisser faire comment pouvait-il dire
que cela ne constituait pas un trouble
alors public quand dans le même temps
vous interdisez des manifestations
syndicales au prétexte qu'on y fait du
bruit avec des casseroles
merci monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur une fois n'est pas coutume
de vous remercier d'avoir recadré le
gouvernement finalement jusqu'à votre
première ministre en ordonnant au préfet
hier d'interdire ce type de
manifestation mais comme vous le savez
le guide à la manœuvre de celle-ci c'est
reconstitué en 2012 nous vous demandons
avec d'autres à nouveau une dissolution
du guide et comptez-vous engagé des
poursuites pour reconstitution de ligne
dissoute
pour vous répondre la parole
est à Madame Sonia baquet
secrétaire d'État chargé de la
citoyenneté vous avez la parole merci
marine
ça a été choqué ça a été dit par la
première ministre par le ministre de
l'intérieur par les images que nous
avons vu de la manifestation de ce
week-end vous avez également entendu les
propos très clairs de Gérald Darmanin
hier le racisme l'antisémitisme n'ont
pas leur place dans la République et
désormais toute manifestation qui porte
ses messages sera interdite
la main du gouvernement de manière
solidaire ne tremble pas quand il s'agit
de combattre l'ultra-droite ce sont
d'ailleurs douze groupuscules dissous en
sacquant en 5 ans qui portait des
messages à caractère raciste antisémites
ou homophobe qui ont été dissous ce sont
plusieurs manifestations du droit droit
qui ont été interdites ces derniers mois
à Lyon à Montpellier à Paris et ce sera
encore dimanche prochain une
manifestation en hommage à Jeanne d'Arc
dans A opéra portée par des groupuscules
d'ultra-droites qui sera interdite par
la par la préfecture de police le
gouvernement continuera sur la question
que vous avez posée en particulier de
combattre de toutes ses forces et par
tous les moyens légaux à sa disposition
les actions à caractère antisémites
racistes porté par l'ultra-droite je
vous remercie
monsieur
vous n'avez pas répondu à ma question
très précise le guide quand il se
reconstitue en 2022 déclaré nous sommes
sur un groupe qui ne cache pas son
racisme ni son antisémitisme c'est eux
qui le disent
vous savez que
est considéré comme la principale menace
en Europe dans les démocraties
occidentales des groupes d'ultra droites
violents qui se propagent on vous
demande d'agir vite
la parole est à notre collègue et rigole
pour le gros du Rassemblement
démocratique et social européen
si monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires
monsieur le ministre l'Assemblée
nationale a voté la semaine dernière
l'ouverture du bouclier tarifaire sur
l'électricité à la très grande majorité
des communes aujourd'hui les tarifs
réglementés de vente d'électricité sont
limitées aux communes qui ont moins de
10 salariés et un budget inférieur à 2
millions d'euros ce vote c'est fait
contre la vie du gouvernement il n'est
certainement pas pertinent d'apporter la
même aide à toutes les communes quel que
soit leur taille et leur situation
financière mais la hausse du coût de
l'énergie fragilise de très nombreuses
collectivités il ne se passe pas une
semaine sans que nous qu'on rencontrions
des élus démunies face à des factures
multipliées par deux trois ou quatre
selon intercommunalité de France la
facture d'énergie a au moins doublé pour
les trois quarts des intercommunalités
il y a sans doute une côte mal taillée
qui serait bon d'ajuster notamment pour
les collectivités les plus en difficulté
la dotation globale de finance de
fonctionnement est réparti et reparti à
la hausse après des années de gel ou de
baisse ce qui devrait donner un peu de
marge aux élus locaux mais du fait de
dépenses incompressible qui augmente je
parlais de l'inflation de l'énergie et
de la hausse du point d'indice les
budgets ont eu bien du mal à être bouclé
cette année cette réalité hypothèque la
capacité des élus à assurer leur mission
de service public à investir et donc à
soutenir l'économie locale je rappelle
que les collectivités représentent 70%
de l'investissement public
l'enjeu est donc important il est
d'autant plus que pour réduire les
factures d'énergie la vague de
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments
publics des gens enclenché doit encore
s'accélérer
mais elle nécessite du temps et de
l'argent aussi parmi les dispositifs
existants qui ont fait leur preuve pour
les publics éligibles en vous
envisageez-vous une extension à
certaines collectivités qui en sont
aujourd'hui exclues je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique de
la cohésion des territoires monsieur
bichu vous avez la parole
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur gold vous savez l'attention qui
est la nôtre autour des finances des
collectivités locales et je sais à quel
point ce sujet ici est un sujet de
préoccupation réparti sur tous les bancs
1er janvier de cette année l'épargne
brute de la totalité des collectivités
locales avait progresser de 2,2
milliards d'euros par rapport au 1er
janvier de l'année précédente avec des
disparités entre les blocs de
collectivité plus 2% de progression pour
l'épargne brute des communes plus 12
pour les intercommunalités plus 5 8 pour
les départements plus fuites pour les
régions mais je sais que ces chiffres
bien qu'il soit aggloméré
reflète des réalités très diverses et
c'est cette diversité que nous avons
voulu prendre en compte deux milliards
et demi dans le cadre du soutien
spécifique sur les énergies boucliers
tarifaires amortisseurs électricité et
les 520 millions d'euros du filet de
sécurité que vous avez voté et pour
lequel nous avons à l'heure actuelle à
faire le bilan de ce que va être son
taux de consommation pour savoir si nous
avons des disponibilités nous venons de
l'étendre aux dépenses ferroviaires des
régions avec Clément Baude nous avions
repéré la nécessité qu'il y avait de
faire en sorte de compléter ce trou dans
la raquette la suite c'est évidemment le
fond vert 2 milliards d'euros qui
s'ajoutent aux 2 milliards de soutiens
l'investissement
10476 dossiers déposés sur les 1300
premiers lauréats pour vous répondre de
manière précise
600 portent sur des projets de
rénovation énergétique et sur le plan
national c'est presque 4000 dossiers
uniquement sur les questions de
rénovation énergétique auxquelles il
convient d'ajouter
2500 dossiers sur la question de la
rénovation de l'éclairage public c'est
dire si votre point d'entrée sur la
volonté des élus de continuer à investir
d'accélérer sur les rénovations
énergétiques et dermiques correspondent
à des réalités la première ministre a
annoncé la pérennisation de ce
dispositif je recevrai le 17 mai toutes
les associations d'élus à la foire pour
faire un point sur la territorialisation
de la planification écologique mais
également pour faire un point plus
précis sur les difficultés que vous avez
remontées et ce qui convient de faire
dans la suite de l'année et à l'occasion
des prochains rendez-vous budgétaires
la parole est à notre collègue Monique
de Marco pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le président
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
la réforme des lycées professionnels
concerne un tiers des lycéens de notre
pays je dis dernier à Saintes le
président de la République a présenté
les détails de ceux qui souhaitent
mettre en place
allongement de la durée des stages aux
dépens des heures d'enseignement
généraux définition des formations par
partenaire et des entreprises avec
orientation des élèves vers les métiers
en tension cela rejoint les propositions
que vous portez depuis l'automne madame
la ministre
la concertation n'a pas fait évoluer les
grandes lignes à part les annonces de
revalorisation inconditionnelles
destinée à apaiser des enseignants
mobilisés contre vos propositions ou
encore le glissement vers
l'apprentissage avec la rémunération des
élèves entre 50 et 100 euros par semaine
rémunération à la charge de l'État et
non des entreprises
beaucoup craignent aujourd'hui un
rattachement pur et simple de la voie
professionnelle au ministère du Travail
ceci en régression totale vis-à-vis de
la mission émancipatrice du lycée madame
la ministre quand allez-vous assumer les
contradictions et venir débattre devant
le Parlement du contenu de cette réforme
point par point
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre de l'idée en charge de
l'enseignement des formations
les sénateurs madame la sénatrice de
Marco je crois que nous pouvons tous ici
nous dire que nous ne pouvons pas nous
satisfaire d'un statu quo il y a
effectivement trop d'échecs de ces
jeunes au lycée professionnel pour
s'insérer dans l'emploi pour poursuivre
des études réussie ainsi que trop de
décrochage notre objectif est donc clair
c'est zéro décrochage et 100% de taux
d'insertion d'ailleurs le programme
2022 des écologistes soutenaient un
enseignement professionnel au cœur de la
transition écologiste c'est donc une
bonne nouvelle je pense avec cette
réforme nous allons le faire former ces
jeunes au métier qui leur ouvrent des
perspectives aux grandes transitions
celle de l'énergie celle de
l'alimentation des mobilités douces du
numérique formé ces jeunes dans le cadre
d'un investissement massif plus d'un
milliard d'euros par an supplémentaires
mis sur les lycées professionnels en
plus du maintien des effectifs des
professeurs de lycée professionnel à la
rentrée prochaine en plus de 400 et TP
qui vien renforcer les équipes CPE
infirmiers et autres personnels
éducatifs en plus des CNRS qui ont été
déployés pour accompagner les projets et
de France de Miss France pour investir
notamment dans les plateaux techniques
dès la rentrée 23 plus de 1000 places
dans des nouvelles formations d'avenir
sont ouvertes et dans votre territoire
par exemple des formations
supplémentaires en cybersécurité ou
biologie spécialisée c'est là aussi que
nous souhaitons placer le lycée
professionnel et l'avenir de ces jeunes
alors non madame la sénatrice ce n'est
pas au lycée professionnel d'apporter
finalement une réponse immédiate aux
entreprises nous préparons l'avenir au
travers de cette réforme l'avenir de ces
jeunes l'avenir aussi des compétences du
pays et pour répondre à plus court terme
nous avons d'autres dispositifs le plan
d'investissement dans les compétences le
CPF la VAE les plantes développement
personnel au font tous ces dispositifs
qui sont déjà en vigueur le gouvernement
souhaite faire donc du lycée
professionnel une voix de choix une voix
reconnue par tous une voix qui permet la
réussite de ces jeunes je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
madame la ministre nous sommes vraiment
loin du programme des écologistes vous
proposez d'augmenter la durée des stages
au détriment de l'enseignement généraux
qui est pour nous à croire que les
inégalités entre la voie générale les
voies professionnelles valoriser
également les stages en entreprise c'est
nier la force de l'enseignement associé
en formation générale et professionnelle
adapter les formations au bassin
d'emploi c'est renforcer des inégalités
territoriales en rendant les lycées
dépendants du tissu économique local un
autre avis cette réforme mérite une loi
dédiée et un vrai débat parlementaire
vous n'y avez pas répondu je pense que
nos lycéens va le mieux que la voie
réglementaire
merci la parole
est à notre collègue Jean-Pierre Grand
pour le groupe Les Indépendants
République et territoires merci monsieur
le président madame la Première ministre
mes chers collègues dans beaucoup de
villes les manifestations du 1er mai ont
dégénéré en violence contre les forces
de l'ordre le mobilier urbain et des
commerces c'est le cas à Montpellier
après avoir connu ces dernières années
pendant deux ans tous les samedis les
exactions des gilets jaunes 140
manifestations en quatre ans des
commerçants rencontrés m'ont informés de
leur découragement de leur peur et de
leur colère
certains qui ont eu à subir plusieurs
sinistres liés aux manifestations et au
casseurs ont vu leur contrats
d'assurance résilié des commerçants se
retrouvent avec difficulté des
compagnies d'assurance qui acceptent de
les couvrir mais qui subordonnent un
nouveau contrat à une période probatoire
de 2 ans sans sinistres ces commerçants
n'ont plus qu'un seul choix incroyable
celui de ne pas déclarer le dernier
sinistre lié aux manifestations du 1er
mai s'ils veulent conserver une
couverture pour des risques plus graves
dans la période probatoire imposée je le
rappelle deux ans
je sais combien cette situation
préoccupées par la Chambre de commerce
de l'Hérault et son président qui avait
l'ensemble des commerçants demande ton
gouvernement de prendre des mesures
législatives au réglementaires pour
dissocier de toutes les autres clauses
contractuelles les risques liés aux
manifestations et aux casseurs ces
commerçants demandent que soit garantie
le maintien d'une couverture
assurancielle dès lors que leur
responsabilité ne peut être mise en
cause ils sont les victimes de ces
sinistres à répétition ils n'en sont pas
les responsables je ne demande pas que
l'État se substitue aux assurances mais
monsieur le ministre si le gouvernement
ce que nous souhaiterions c'est que le
gouvernement intègre cette situation
vitale pour beaucoup d'entre eux dans le
prochain plan en faveur des commerces de
proximité merci
pour vous répondre la parole des cas au
ministre Jean-Noël baron
ministre délégué en charge de la
transition numérique et des difficultés
communication c'est le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur grand je vous prie
d'excuser l'absence d'Olivia Grégoire
retenu à 7h avec le ministre du Tourisme
chinois la situation que vous décrivez
pour les commerçants et roter
malheureusement une situation que les
commerçants de Rennes de Lille de Lyon
comme de Paris pourraient décrire autant
que le gouvernement déplore que les
manifestations entraînent parfois des
dégradations il déplore que ces
difficultés emportent de lourdes
conséquences pour les commerçants
concernant la couverture par les
assurances il faut distinguer le cas des
dommages matériels vitrines par exemple
et le cas des pertes d'exploitation par
exemple quand un commerce est trop
endommagé et que des travaux impliquent
sa fermeture pour les dommages matériels
les assurances sont en première ligne
les conséquences des dégradations étant
prise en charge dans les contrats
multirisques professionnels contractés
par les commerçants
s'agissant de la garrigue garantie perte
d'exploitation elle peut être étendue
aux conséquences d'autres événements que
ceux prévus par les garanties du contrat
comme les actes de vandalisme et les
émeutes de manifestation par exemple à
condition que ces événements soient
intégrés au contrat la couverture des
dégradations liées à des manifestations
n'est donc pas systématique nous
estimons la part d'artisans commerçant
couvert par une perte d'exploitation à
54%, ce taux est d'autant plus élevé que
l'entreprise est grande concernant la
résiliation unilatérale des contrats par
les assureurs juridiquement la loi
prévoit cette possibilité en cas
d'aggravation du risque mais le
gouvernement veille à ce que des délais
de carence d'incidentes ne soient pas
demandés aux commerçants s'agissant
enfin du cas très particulier que vous
remontez au nom de ma collègue Olivier
Grégoire je prends l'engagement que nous
y regarderons de plus près en lien avec
votre chambre de commerce et d'industrie
si vous en êtes d'accord j'ajoute que
l'État est et restera également présent
pour accompagner les commerçants touchés
consignes a été donné au DG FIP et aux
urssafs d'appliquer avec souplesse les
modalités de remise gracieuse aux
commerçants infectés par les
manifestations et les dégradations ces
interventions exceptionnelles
s'intègrent aux actions que le
gouvernement mène au quotidien en
soutient des commerçants de proximité
plafonnement de l'indice des loyers
déploiement d'action cœur de ville et
petite ville de demain entre autres vous
pouvez donc compter sur la mobilisation
permanente du gouvernement sous
l'autorité de la première ministre et
notamment de Bruno Le Maire et Olivier
Grégoire pour soutenir je vous remercie
monsieur grand
vous avez quelques secondes
je vais monsieur le Président les
utiliser pour me faire le porte-parole
de nos concitoyens je le dis avec calme
mais je le dis parce que je le ressens
sur le terrain le peuple ne supporte
plus ces manifestations violentes
aujourd'hui nous remonte de partout sur
le terrain
un sentiment d'exaspération nous sommes
en République beaucoup l'ignorent
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Philippe
Tabarro pour le groupe les républicains
[Musique]
monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'éducation
nationale monsieur le ministre je suis
le repas d'un garçon qui va faire sa
rentrée en CE1 en septembre
à l'instar des milliers de familles des
Alpes-Maritimes j'ai été invité à
étudier la proposition de l'Inspection
Académique de faire bénéficier à mon
fils de cours en arabe en turc ou en
portugais dans le cadre des
enseignements internationaux avec les
pays d'y partenaire j'ai cru naïvement
le président de la République en 2020
lors de son discours sur le séparatisme
à Mulhouse qui disait vouloir mettre fin
aux dérives des enseignements de langue
et de culture d'origine cette
proposition de votre ministère transmise
aux familles prouve le contraire
qui valide le choix des enseignants de
leurs qualification le contenu des
enseignements pour qu'ils soient
respectueux de nos valeurs républicaines
alors qu'on apprend par la presse que
les contrôles sont encore et toujours
inopérants pourquoi ne pas mettre fin au
risque de dérive communautarisme comme
le pointé déjà nos collègues sénateurs
des 2003 pourquoi tout simplement ne pas
en finir avec les influences étrangères
ces enseignements clivent au lieu de
rassembler et surtout encourage le repli
communautaire monsieur le ministre prend
ton véritablement le bon chemin de
l'intégration en dispensant aux élèves
de primaire l'arabe ou encore le Turc
langue d'un pays avec lequel nous ne
partageons aucune frontière peu de
valeur et dont l'influence en France est
inquiétante alors que le niveau de nos
élèves est en constante diminution ne
serait-il pas préférable de se recentrer
sur l'accès aux fondamentaux et de faire
une seule et véritable priorité la
maîtrise de la langue française
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale de la
jeunesse monsieur Papin
[Musique]
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Tabaro tout d'abord bonne
rentrée future à votre fils en septembre
prochain en CE1 comme vous le savez
effectivement depuis 2020 et le discours
du président de la République sur le
séparatisme à Mulhouse les enseignements
internationaux de langue étrangères ont
remplacé les enseignements de langue et
de culture d'origine en précisant les
conditions d'exercice et en recadrant
ces enseignements ses enseignements sont
évidemment facultatif à l'école
élémentaire du CE1 au CM2 c'est une
heure et demie en plus des enseignements
obligatoires et il concerne quatre
langues l'arabe le turque le portugais
et l'italien afin d'éviter toute dérive
communautaire ou toutes influence
étrangère ce nouveau dispositif a permis
d'instaurer un cadre homogène basé sur
un accord bilatéral entre les pays
d'imposer que les enseignants est un
niveau minimal de langue française qui
est contrôlée des leur entrée en
fonction à un niveau B2
d'adosser le programme d'enseignement de
la langue dans le cadre européen de
référence pour les langues et enfin
comme vous l'indiquez de renforcer les
contrôles puisque dans chaque
département il y a un inspecteur de
l'Éducation nationale qui est missionné
pour le contrôle de ses enseignants de
langue étrangères il ne s'agit donc pas
de promotion particulière de ces langues
mais de leur permettre de les apprendre
dans un cadre qui est celui de l'école
républicaine dans un cadre qui est celui
de l'éducation nationale plutôt que dans
d'autres lieux qui ne seraient pas
nécessairement adéquat et donc cet
enseignement qui concerne environ 70 000
élèves soient à peu près 1% des élèves
de l'école élémentaire se déroule
désormais dans des conditions
acceptables
c'est le Ministre j'habite à 40 km de
l'Italie et on m'a pas proposé l'italien
premièrement et deuxièmement je suis un
farouche partisan de l'école libre
pourtant j'ai toujours été fier de dire
que j'avais fait mon cursus scolaire au
sein de l'école publique et j'avais le
même souhait pour mes enfants mais vous
contribuez fortement malgré des
enseignants méritants à faire de notre
école à lieu de séparatisme de
communautarisme et d'échecs scolaire
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à notre collègue Olivier
Hainaut pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre ma question concerne le service
public postale symbolisé par le timbre
rouge mais aussi par la voiture jaune
chair à Ajac alors aujourd'hui ce sont
des vélos jaunes électriques qui l'ont
remplacé et tant mieux alors il s'agit
pas de nier les évolutions
technologiques Internet les mails le
numérique encore que si on fait un peu
de poésie il y a toujours la place pour
un peu de poésie on a tous une autre
coeur qui vibrait à la réception d'une
lettre d'amour dans notre boîte aux
lettres et puis à la à la lecture de
cette de cette lettre mais ma question
concerne les craintes des mers vis-à-vis
de nouvelles vagues de fermeture de
bureau de Poste dans les communes
rurales mais aussi dans les communes de
moyenne importance puisqu'il s'agit des
communes de moyenne importance alors je
vais pas faire comme Georges Marchais
par rapport à Jean-Pierre elkabba je
voyais je connais les bons auteurs poser
les questions et donner les réponses
mais c'est moins des explications au
moins le pourquoi que nous attendons que
la vision du gouvernement sur le service
public postal je vous remercie
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur Hainaut merci pour votre
question et pour votre témoignage qui
sentait bon le vécu
en mars dernier comme comme vous le
savez nous avons signé le sixième
contrat de présence postale territoriale
qui a été négocié entre l'AMF entre la
poste et l'État et qui définit pour la
période à venir 2023 2025 les modalités
d'évolution de la présence postale sur
les territoires ce contrat tient compte
de la période passée dès de son
évaluation ainsi que des recommandations
du rapport sénatorial de vos collègues
Patrick chèvre Rémy Cardon et pierrelot
avec mes collègues Dominique Faure Bruno
Le Maire et Gabriel Attal nous avons
veillé à ce que 5 priorités s'y
retrouvent d'abord conforter la présence
postale dans un contexte vous l'avez dit
de baisse significative de la
fréquentation des guichets en
accompagnant notamment le déploiement du
dispositif France service sur lequel
veille Stanislas Guerini en bureau de
poste 17000 points de contact sont ainsi
maintenus sur le territoire ensuite
préserver le niveau de financement à
hauteur de 74 millions d'euros
troisièmement l'amélioration de
l'accessibilité horaire des bureaux de
poste qui seront ouverts plus souvent le
samedi et le jour des événements locaux
quatrième point le développement des
usages numériques et de la médiation
sociale à destination des populations
les plus vulnérables et enfin
l'optimisation des règles de gouvernance
et de fonctionnement des commissions
départementales pour une meilleure
utilisation du fond de peréquation
j'ajoute que les actions qui figurent ce
contrats bénéficient de manière
prioritaire aux zones rurales aux zones
de montagne au quartier prioritaire de
la politique de la ville et aux
outre-mer et qu'en fin l'état indiqué
son intention de poursuivre son soutien
en complément des abattements fiscaux au
moyen d'une dotation budgétaire dans le
montant sera déterminé dans le cadre des
projets de loi de finances 2024 et 2025
nous aurons donc l'occasion d'en
débattre ici vous le voyez monsieur le
sénateur le gouvernement veille à ce que
la présence postale sur les territoires
restent intacts
monsieur Hainaut merci Monsieur le
Ministre évidemment les propos sont
implacables mais je pense essentielles
dans ce domaine de ne pas pêcher par
excès de rationalité
le service postal dans notre pays est un
symbole de l'État un c'est un symbole de
présence territoriale et c'est aussi un
symbole de reconquête territoriale et je
pense essentiel et je vais conclure en
faisant peut-être un mauvais jeu de mots
mais pour nous c'est l'occasion d'une
conviction c'est l'antidote au
déclassement le service public postal et
puis c'est aussi un facteur de
reconquête territoriale je vous remercie
merci
la parole de notre collègue Eric Bocquet
pour le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen et écologiste et merci monsieur
le président madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre des comptes publics
mais je sais qu'il est empêché et que
c'est le Ministre chargé l'industrie
monsieur Lescure qui me répondra le
ministral fut hier dans tous les médias
afin de présenter son plan de lutte
contre la fraude fiscale il a déclaré
vouloir je cite faire payer les impôts
aux ultra-riches et aux multinationales
qui fraudent fichtre voilà un discours
auquel nous n'avions pas été habitué
depuis 2017 vous étiez en effet plutôt
sur le registre de l'Hymne à l'amour
vous annoncez vouloir renforcer le
service d'enquête judiciaire mais dans
le même temps la direction générale des
finances publiques va subir 3000
suppressions d'emplois supplémentaires
d'ici 2027
nous notons avec intérêt l'idée d'une
Coop de la fiscalité et la création d'un
Conseil d'évaluation sans doute une
nouvelle mouture de l'Observatoire
imaginée par votre illustre prédécesseur
en septembre 2018 une instance qui
malheureusement n'a jamais vu le jour je
crains un monsieur le ministre qu'il est
un angle mort majeur dans votre
dispositif c'est celui des paradis
fiscaux
considérez-vous comme Bruxelles qui
n'existe pas de paradis fiscal au sein
de l'Union européenne souvenez-vous un
peu des révélations du journal Le Monde
en février 2021 dans l'affaire open luxe
nous y apprenions que le Luxembourg
hébergé 55000 sociétés offshore dont
17000 détenus par des compatriotes
français cumulant ensemble 6500
milliards d'euros d'actifs on ne peut
pas à cet instant évoquer la fraude
fiscale sans parler de l'évasion fiscale
allez vous prendre des initiatives au
plan européen sur ce sujet n'y a-t-il
pas lieu de mettre sérieusement à jour
la liste française des paradis fiscaux
qui comprend aujourd'hui des états aussi
fondamentaux sans mépris pour eux que le
Vanuatu les Palaos et les Fidji mais
aucun État membre de l'Union européenne
Albert Camus disait mal nommer les
choses c'est ajouter aux malheurs du
monde au niveau des mesures répressives
je pense que les potentiels fraudeurs
fiscaux tremblent des froids à l'idée
d'être déchu de leurs droits civique
enfin je n'ai pu m'empêcher de sourire
on imaginant un instant le PDG d'Amazon
monsieur Jeff Bezos un pinceau à la main
en train de repeindre les murs de la
perception d'Armentières dans le Nord
dans le cadre d'une peine de travaux
d'intérêt général
on vous répondent la parole est au
ministre déléguée chargé de l'Industrie
monsieur Ronan Lescure merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur avec
Bocquet vous l'avez dit Gabriel Attal
est retenu avec Bruno Le Maire
l'Assemblée nationale pour un débat
d'orientation des finances publiques il
m'a donc chargé de vous répondre non pas
sur l'aire de l'Hymne à l'amour je n'ai
ni le talent ni la voix d'Édith Piaf
mais pour commencer par vous remercier
quand même en mon nom mais surtout en
son nom pour le travail que vous avez
fait sur ce sujet depuis longtemps vous
aviez mené une mission d'information je
pense même que c'est une commission
d'enquête au Sénat en 2012 vous avez
participé à toutes les réunions du
groupe de travail qu'à monter Gabriel
Attal en ce début d'année et je pense
que vous avez été aussi un membre
extrêmement actif de la commission
d'enquête du Sénat qui durant l'année
2022 a fait les travaux et oui ces
travaux nous ont inspirés notamment sur
ce que vous appelez la COP fiscale qui
va permettre de parfaire les relations
et le travail de coopération au niveau
international pour traquer la fraude
fiscale là où elle est vous le savez je
pense depuis 6 ans le gouvernement a
fait des choses sur ce sujet si les
multinationales sont désormais taxées à
un niveau minimal dans le monde c'est
grâce au gouvernement français c'est
grâce à la détermination de son
gouvernement de notre gouvernement qui a
porté ce sujet au niveau international
et nous allons continuer à le faire dans
le cadre de 7 comme fiscale par ailleurs
nous allons vous le savez renforcer les
moyens domestiques pour traquer la
fraude fiscale avec 1500 agents
supplémentaires d'ici la fin du
quinquennat on va avoir aussi des moyens
nouveaux modernes de traquer les flux et
de traquer y compris les flux des
personnes pour s'assurer que celles et
ceux qui ne sont pas en France en tout
cas légalement ne réside pas en France
ou n'y passe pas trop de temps et on va
par ailleurs évidemment vous le savez
aussi travailler sur la symétrie des
relations entre l'administration et les
contribuables quand un contribuable
commet une erreur il paye des intérêts
de retard il est important que
l'administration en face d'eux-mêmes
vis-à-vis de contribuables qui auraient
eux-mêmes souffert d'une erreur vous
voyez nous ne mégotons pas sur les
moyens à la fois domestique à
l'international
et nous continuons cette lutte contre
l'optimisation fiscale voire même la
fraude fiscale sur laquelle nous
souhaitons augmenter les moyens et nous
allons le faire merci
merci la parole de notre collègue Martin
de Sidrac
pour le gros les républicains
le président monsieur le ministre
le 66 donne des objectifs de collecte
que la France doit atteindre pour le
recyclage des bouteilles en plastique
elle indique également les étapes à
suivre pour pouvoir évaluer cette
trajectoire et surtout elle précise
qu'en concertation avec les parties
prenantes notamment les collectivités le
gouvernement peut définir après la
publication du bilan Adam prévu et
attendu en 2023 et après évaluation des
impacts environnementaux économiques les
modalités d'une éventuelle mise en
oeuvre de la concis tel était le
préalable indispensable à toute décision
sur la consigne que l'on ne soit
favorable ou non or sans attendre les
résultats de l'étude de l'ADEME vous
avez lancé votre propre évaluation des
janvier cette méthode interpelle vous en
conviendrait monsieur le ministre vous
enjambez sans égard les engagements pris
et fixés dans la loi laissant planer le
doute sur vos réelles intentions les
parties prenantes et particulièrement
les élus s'inquiète et s'interrogent
surtout au regard des investissements
lourds engagés dans leur territoire
en faveur de la transition écologique ma
question monsieur le ministre
franchement quels sont vos intentions
[Applaudissements]
de la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires monsieur le
président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice de Sidrac je
m'adresse au temps à la sénatrice
qu'elle a la présidente du groupe
d'études de l'économie circulaire et
donc à ce titre je vais vous répondre
sur le même registre que vous m'avez
posé la question la loi anti-gaspillage
prévoit qu'au premier semestre 2023
obligatoirement le gouvernement lance
une concertation c'est comme certains
elle a été lancée par Bérengère
Couillard ma secrétaire d'État le 30
janvier dernier
c'est une concertation il n'y a aucune
décision prise parce que la réalité
c'est qu'il y a des disparités dans
notre pays qui devraient nous
interpeller
l'objectif de la loi anti-gaspillage
c'est 77% de recyclage des bouteilles en
plastique en 2025 90% en 2029 et c'est
pour les emballages plastiques 50% de
recyclage en 2025
55 en 2029 nous sommes à 60% pour les
bouteilles en plastique pour 77% dans
deux ans et nous sommes seulement à 25%
pour les emballages plastiques pour 50%
dans deux ans mais derrière ces chiffres
il y a d'énormes disparités
la région Île-de-France la région
Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur sont aux
alentours de 40% pour les bouteilles en
plastique pour une moyenne de 60 à
l'inverse
ou qui n'en font pas et avec des
disparités à l'échelle des grandes
villes qui sont assez saisissantes quand
on les regarde et qui permettent de
mesurer que c'est pas nécessairement
ceux qui parlent d'écologie qui font le
plus de recyclage
madame de Sidrac
[Applaudissements]
je vous remercie pour de nous avoir
rappelé
tous les jalouagesques les objectifs
bien évidemment vous-même vous avez dit
que nous avons des régions et des
départements qui sont tout à fait dans
la bonne trajectoire ce sans consigne ce
qui laisse supposer aussi que nous avons
d'autres moyens pour y parvenir très
bien je voudrais aussi quand même vous
rappeler monsieur le ministre que dans
le cadre de la loi GEC dans le cadre de
tout ce que nous évoquons en ce moment
il y a un véritable enjeu
environnemental qui n'est pas
suffisamment porté vous avez évoqué
l'enjeu économique mais il y a aussi un
véritable enjeu de pouvoir achat de pour
les Français donc je pense qu'il faut
que nous ayons c'est considérations là
et pour ne pas être trop longue je me
félicite monsieur le ministre que le
Sénat est pris la décision d'avoir une
mission d'information sur la consigne en
ce moment nous menons un grand nombre
d'auditions et nous voyons bien que sur
la consigne nous sommes très loin du
consensus et j'espère que à l'occasion
de votre rencontre avec les associations
des élus vous allez tenir compte des 14
propositions qui vous ont été faites je
vous remercie
la parole est à notre collègue Franck
montoger pour le gros socialisme
écologiste et républicain
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
chers collègues l'inflation s'est
installée durablement à un haut niveau
dans notre société de très nombreux
Français vivent au quotidien une
austérité de fait qui affecte
sensiblement leur pouvoir de vivre alors
que les défis environnementaux et
sociaux sont immenses le rétablissement
des comptes publics ne doit pas se faire
au détriment de l'action publique celle
de l'État comme celle des collectivités
qui sont en première ligne auprès de nos
concitoyens au terme de l'année 2023
l'inflation ce sera traduite par une
perte à Euro constant de plus de 1
milliard d'euros pour la seule DGF
l'inflation est très supérieure à 10%
pour le panier du maire et elle va durer
à ce niveau vous ne pouvez pas laisser
l'action publique locale s'affaiblir
durablement
dans ce contexte les élus constatent que
les filets de sécurité et autres
amortisseurs ont des limites en matière
d'investissement des préfectures
constatent des taux de réalisation
d'appels 60% sur le cycle de mandat et
rendent des crédits
il n'est pas normal que des
collectivités renoncent à l'action pour
cause de capacité d'autofinancement
dégradée par la conjoncture ou de
complexité administrative de gestion des
dossiers par exemple une gestion
différente des dossiers éligibles à la
DETR devait être devrait être proposé
par votre gouvernement pour soutenir les
projets des élus locaux madame la
ministre quelle mesure structurelle et
durable envisagez-vous de prendre pour
préserver voir restaurer les capacités
de fonctionnement et d'investissement de
nos collectivités locales
pour vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité madame Dominique Faure merci
monsieur
le
monsieur le sénateur monte alors pour la
première fois depuis 13 ans et vous le
savez bien le gouvernement a décidé
d'une hausse exceptionnelle de 320
millions d'euros en loi de finances qui
a permis à 90% des communes de voir leur
DGF augmenté dans la ruralité que vous
connaissez bien monsieur le sénateur
c'est 94% de nos communes dans la DGF a
augmenté je vais vous répondre si vous
me le permettez et donc 80% des communes
envoient leur vu leur DGF augmenter
et assez hausse de DGF s'ajoutent à
l'ensemble des mesures décidées en loi
de finance pour 2023 pour soutenir les
finances des collectivités territoriales
et vous l'avez cité le bouclier
tarifaire l'amortisseur électricité le
filet de sécurité l'amène tient le
maintien des dotations d'investissement
alors plus au niveau la création du fond
vert et la revalorisation des bases de
fiscalité locale à hauteur de 7%. je
rappelle à ce titre que pour 2023 la
somme des mesures prévues pour les
collectivités étaient plus importantes
qu'une simple indexation de la DGF sur
l'inflation 2 milliards 8 en loi de
finances initiale pour 2023 tandis
qu'une indexation sur la DGF n'aurait
conduit à une augmentation que de 1
milliard 100 comme vous l'avez indiqué
en 2023 cet effort significatif montre
la volonté du gouvernement d'apporter un
soutien continu aux communes et
particulièrement à celles confronté à
des difficultés économiques et sociales
l'intégralité des conséquences de
l'inflation doit faire l'objet d'un
effort commun des collectivités
territoriales et de l'État en résumé
comme l'indiquer je suis précédemment
bien que la situation financière des
collectivités locales afin 2022 soit
encore meilleur qu'à fin 2021 il y a
beaucoup d'hétérogénéité je suis
d'accord dans les situations mais le
nombre de communes en épargne brut
négatif baisse diminue très
significativement je suis
personnellement avec l'aide de la DGCL
non non
[Rires]
écoutez sur votre disposition ainsi qu'à
celle des communes de votre département
monsieur Montauger va compléter allez-y
oui je vais pas compléter la réponse
mais simplement dire que je partage pas
du tout l'analyse qui vient de nous être
présentée écoutez madame en vous
écoutant un nombre de collectivités vont
connaître des jours très difficiles et
moi j'ai compris qu'elles sont parties
intégrante du plan d'austérité que vous
êtes en train de mettre en place à
l'inverse nous penchons que pour
répondre aux besoins des Français les
moyens des collectivités doivent être
préservées à tout prix nous restons avec
les élus locaux dans l'attention de
mesures rapidement efficaces merci
la parole est à notre collègue Cédric
Vial pour le groupe les républicains
c'est le Président mes chers collègues
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur papel
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
monsieur le ministre
430000 élèves sont reconnus en situation
du handicap soit en moyenne un élève par
classe
il est de la responsabilité de votre
ministère mais c'est aussi une question
de justice sociale d'humanité et donneur
pour notre pays d'accompagner au mieux
ses enfants et adolescents vers plus
d'autonomie et vers la réussite scolaire
il est vrai que ces dernières années des
moyens importants ont été mis en oeuvre
par l'État pour favoriser leur prise en
charge et leurs accompagnements humains
grâce au recrutement massif d’aesh au
nombre de 135 000 ils sont aujourd'hui
le deuxième métier de l'éducation
nationale
toutefois en l'absence d'une
organisation adaptée et d'une véritable
approche éducative centrée autour des
besoins spécifiques de ses enfants notre
système a atteint ses limites et ne
permet pas de répondre aux attentes des
enfants et des familles concernées et
mais même parfois l'institution scolaire
en difficulté
dans un récent rapport que j'ai rendu au
nom de la commission de la culture et de
l'éducation du Sénat nous appelons à
franchir une nouvelle étape dans la mise
en oeuvre d'une politique d'inclusion
scolaire efficace
s'appuyant sur une vingtaine de
préconisations nous vous proposons de
mettre en place un cadre culturel rénové
avec une organisation administrative
profondément corrigée en faisant de
l'accessibilité pédagogique la priorité
qu'elle n'aurait jamais dû cesser d'être
en prenant une prise en charge des
élèves plus qualitative et continue en
améliorant les relations avec les
familles en renforçant les liens avec le
secteur médico-social et en respectant
et professionnalisant le beau métier
d'Ash
alors que la Conférence nationale du
handicap a créé plus de déceptions
qu'elle ne suscite d'espoir monsieur le
ministre êtes-vous prêt à travailler sur
la base des propositions du Sénat à la
création d'un véritable service public
de l'inclusion scolaire pour vous
répondre
la parole est obligé d'éducation
nationale et de la jeunesse monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Cédric Vial je veux
d'abord vous remercier pour votre récent
rapport d'information
dont je partage les constats et une
bonne partie des propositions vous
l'avez dit 430 000 élèves en situation
de handicap scolarisés en milieu
ordinaire plus de 130
000 aesh 3,8 milliards d'euros de budget
annuel pour l'école inclusive ce sont
des chiffres importants mais vous
pointez les difficultés que nous
connaissons qui ont motivé les
propositions que nous a que le Président
de la République a fait lors de la
conférence nationale sur le handicap qui
s'est tenu le 26 avril dernier
proposition très substantielle et nous
aurons d'ailleurs l'occasion d'échanger
ensemble à ce sujet dès la rentrée 2023
tous les enfants scolarisés y compris
ceux en milieu
médicaux sociales bénéficieront d'un
identifiant national qui les rattachera
à l'éducation nationale et qui permettra
de suivre leur scolarité pour ce qui
concerne les aesh nous avons à la fois à
progresser sur leur temps de travail
nous avançons du côté du périscolaire
avec les collectivités mais nous
proposons aussi de rapprocher les aesh
de la vie scolaire des assistants
d'éducation de manière à augmenter le
temps de travail à les attacher à un
établissement et à enrichir leur métier
par ailleurs nous proposons également en
amont des notifications MDPH donc vous
connaissez les difficultés que nous
rencontrons à leur sujet de transformer
les pial
structure qui puisse accueillir et
également évaluer les besoins des élèves
nous allons aussi permettre aux
enseignants d'investir dans l'adaptation
pédagogique avec la formation des
équipes avec des enseignants référents
dans les écoles et avec un
investissement de du matériel
pédagogique adapté et puis enfin nous
allons vers une coopération et un
rapprochement entre le médico-social et
l'école bref l'ambition que je porte
avec le gouvernement monsieur le
sénateur sur l'avenir de l'école
inclusive elle est très largement je
crois présentent dans votre rapport et
nous aurons l'occasion encore une fois
d'échanger à ce sujet
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Jocelyne guidez pour le groupe de
l'Union centriste
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse aux ministres de la santé et
de la prévention dynamique tout au long
de la crise sanitaire les collectivités
ont demandé à participer plus activement
à la gouvernance des agences régionales
de santé pour mieux coordonner les
réponses institutionnelles sur le
terrain actuellement les ARS sont
présidés par un conseil de surveillance
qui se réunit trimestre
remulguée le 21 février 2022 a prévu le
remplacement de ce conseil de
surveillance par un conseil
d'administration cette mesure vise à
renforcer l'ancrage territorial de ces
établissements publics ainsi que le rôle
des parlementaires afin de corriger le
fonctionnement d'une administration trop
centralisée en tant que membre du Sénat
j'étais désigné le 22 avril 2022 par le
président Gérard Larcher pour si j'ai
avec voix consultative au sein du
conseil d'administration de la RS
Île-de-France et ma collègue Nadia
Soulou que j'associe à ma question l'a
été pour la RS Bourgogne Franche-Comté
n'ayant pas reçu de convocation ainsi
que tous mes collègues sénateurs pour
participer aux réunions de cet instant
j'ai découvert à ma grande surprise que
les décrets d'applications organisant
l'évolution de ce conseil non pas été
publiées ce jour par conséquent la
direction des ARS ne peuvent pas
modifier le fonctionnement actuel pour
contribuer au projet qui répondent aux
besoins des territoires notamment au
défi de la désertification médicale les
membres titulaires de ce futur conseil
d'administration attendent impatiemment
la publication de ses décrets
pourriez-vous monsieur le ministre
m'apportait plus de précisions à ce
sujet et m'indiquer votre plan d'action
pour accélérer l'évolution de ces
dispositions
merci
pour vous répondre la parole
électronique de la santé de la
prévention monsieur Braun
mais si merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame sénatrice guidez
associée plus et mieux les élus au
pilotage à la refondation de notre
système de santé vous le savez c'est
l'esprit même des CNR santé qui se sont
déroulés sur tous les territoires qui
continuent à se dérouler aujourd'hui en
associant les élus les citoyens les
professionnels de santé c'est la méthode
c'est l'esprit qui est conduite par ce
gouvernement dialogue et en concertation
sur le terrain je ne peux donc que
souscrire bien sûr voir me réjouir des
dispositions de la loi 3DS qui va nous
permettre de rénover le pilotage de nos
Ars en donnant plus de pas de place aux
élus le nombre des élus va être
multiplié par deux dans ces nouveaux
conseils d'administration des ARS
vous le savez aussi mettre en
application les lois qui sont votées par
ce Parlement est une de mes priorités
en témoigne la mise en application
récemment de la loi qui plafonne
l'intérim médical et qui a été longtemps
attendu
concernant le décret dont vous parlez la
présidente de roche m'a également
interprété interpellé hier sur son
absence de parution que je regrette tout
comme vous mais je peux vous rassurer le
travail se fait en gouvernemental en
intergouvernementale et se poursuit avec
les différentes parties prenantes mon
objectif étant la publication de ce
éclairer courant l'été je vous remercie
madame guidez qui attendra l'été donc
[Rires]
[Musique]
moi je trouve que c'est assez obèse
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui nous avons
été désignés depuis maintenant plus d'un
an et on peut toujours pas iciger donc
bientôt il y aura des sénatoriales je
pense que je sais pas si j'aurai la
chance d'ici j'ai un jour
d'ici voilà donc monsieur le monsieur le
ministre dépêchez-vous parce que ça
devient très urgent
le Journal Officiel porte la date du 10
juin 2022 concernant madame guidez et
d'autres collègues voilà la parole est à
notre collègue Vincent Segoin pour le
groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre le 15 avril dernier la Caisse
des dépôts est consignations
propriétaires de nombreuses forêts à
suspendu tous ces chantiers jusqu'à
nouvel ordre et il en va de même pour la
direction interdépartemental des routes
qui veille à la sûreté routière
Césarée font suite à une décision de
l'Office français de la biodiversité
s'appuyant sur l'article l411 du code de
l'environnement qui interdit toute
destruction d'habitat et qui suspendent
tous entiers en forêt ou sur bosquet les
30 entreprises de travaux forestiers
voient leur carnet de commandes
s'annuler cela concerne près de 200 000
chantiers de 7 véhicules d'entretien et
de récolte ouvert chaque année
les entreprises nous alertent car elles
se retrouvent donc sans activité pendant
une période minimum de 5 mois non défini
et dépendant de l'arbitrage de l'ofv
dorénavant elles seront incapables
d'exploiter les bois en milieu humide de
réaliser en 7 mois les travaux annuels
et de produire le besoin national en
bois
dois-je vous rappeler monsieur le
ministre que les entreprises du bois
contribué à la protection contre les
incendies comme nous l'avons souhaité
dans les textes sur le risque incendie
voté en avril et en réponse aux
importants incendies de 2022 le bois est
aussi le matériau nécessaire à la
construction et à la lutte contre la
précarité énergétique des logements la
pénurie créera de l'inflation et
contribuera à la crise du logement
naissante enfin le bois est une source
d'énergie renouvelable nous permettant
de lutter contre la dépendance aux
énergies fossiles sans exploitation
temporaire les entreprises vont devoir
recourir au chômage partiel à l'arrêt de
l'investissement voir la cessation
d'activités seront-elles les prochaines
victimes
de la désindustrialisation de la France
de plus l'interprétation de l'article du
code de l'environnement par l'OSB qui
voit un danger dans tout le chantier en
forêt me paraît abusive et éloignée de
la volonté du législateur une question
monsieur le ministre que comptez-vous
faire dans un futur immédiat et de façon
durable pour les entreprises du bois qui
comme toutes les autres ne peuvent vivre
sans travailler
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre de la transition écologique de
la cohésion des territoires
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur c'est quoi je vais pas vous
dire ce que nous allons faire je vais
vous dire ce que nous avons déjà fait
ces inquiétudes elles nous ont été
remontées et vous avez raison de les
pointer on a un enjeu crucial plus large
que la question vous évoquez sur la
totalité de notre gestion forestière en
France
à la fois parce que ça peut être un axe
de réindustrialisation de soutien à la
décarbonation et de stockage de carbone
cette brique essentielle de la
planification écologique elle a été
précisée sous l'autorité de la première
ministre avec ce plan de plantation d'un
milliard d'arbre mais qui soulève
quelques angles dont il faut qu'on
s'occupe un dont il est pas la question
ici qui concerne les ondulés et un
deuxième que vous soulevez et qui est la
difficulté qui est liée aux injonctions
qui sont liées pour une part à la
Directive Habitat et oiseau endroit
européen avec les déclinaisons
françaises et de l'autre les questions
qui touchent auprès des obligations
légales de débroussaillement et plus
largement des travaux silicone de
récolte d'entretien ou tout simplement
d'aménagement 200
000 chantiers sylvicoll 15
verbalisations ça c'est le chiffre
c'est exactement le même que l'année
dernière à la même époque il n'y a pas
eu la moindre évolution de
réglementation et il n'y a pas eu
d'augmentation de ce chiffre en revanche
cette incompréhension de vous faites le
porte-parole elle met parvenue j'ai donc
demandé au délégué interministériel fort
et bois de réunir l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés à la fois les ONG et toutes
les entreprises qui vit collent en
liaison étroite avec le ministère de
l'Agriculture tient la compétence sur la
récolte silicone les conclusions nous
sont parvenues à la fin du mois d'avril
nous avons consulté les acteurs
forestiers c'est tout dernier jour et
les conclusions pour clarifier les
règles leur conviennent parce qu'on a
bien ce double enjeu de lieu qui sont
des sanctuaires de biodiversité et qui
dans le même temps méritent d'être
travaillé par l'homme concilier les deux
c'est le sens de ce que nous allons
rendre public avec marcéno dans les tous
prochains jours mais qui je le redis a
fait l'objet de cette consultation avec
les têtes de réseau à la fois sylvicole
et ONG pour trouver la voie de compromis
qui permettent de tenir les deux bouts
de cette chaîne absolument indispensable
merci beaucoup pour votre question
monsieur second
la parole
ça notre collègue Emilienne pomirol pour
le groupe socialiste écologiste et
républicain
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur Miss des
solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées
après l'immobilisme de votre
gouvernement lors du quinquennat
précédent il aura fallu attendre un
drame pour que vous saisissiez du sujet
de la petite enfance et des crèches nous
le savons pourtant la situation n'est
pas nouvelle et après les emmener de
sous-investissement et de
déréglementation le constat dressé
aujourd'hui par le rapport de
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales est sans appel ainsi les gaz
souligne que sur le plan systémique les
conditions ne sont pas réunies à ce jour
pour garantir une qualité d'accueil dans
les crèches le rapport point ainsi du
doigt à la fois la maltraitance
institutionnelle qui pèse sur les
professionnels un taux d'encadrement
trop faible une formation insuffisante
des professionnels des modes de
financement inadéquats une gouvernance
incontrol qui doivent être renforcés et
il va plus loin en faisant le parallèle
avec la situation des EHPAD en effet le
rapport de notes que le secteur des
crèches dit également marqué par une
domination de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en général des affaires sociales pour
faire la lumière sur la situation dans
les crèches nous assurer que de la
robustesse des règles appliquées dans
ces dans ces crèches nous assurer de la
qualité aussi des contrôles et puis j'ai
demandé à ce que les inspecteurs nous
fassent un certain nombre de
propositions les constats ou les avez
vous les avez dit mais un constat me
semble-t-il et important de noter c'est
que la question de l'hétérogénéité de la
qualité de l'accueil se retrouve dans
tous les secteurs publics associatifs et
privés commerciales et donc n'est pas
l'apanage d'un seul de ces de ces
secteurs beaucoup a dû à la pénurie de
professionnels dans dans ces crèches
beaucoup est dû aussi au manque
d'intégration des connaissances sur le
jeune enfant dans les projets
d'établissement et dans la formation des
professionnels vous l'avez dit et puis
dans les limites des contrôles qui sont
portés aujourd'hui par les services de
PMI des départements vous le savez j'ai
fait de la lutte contre les
maltraitances une priorité de mon mandat
j'ai lancé récemment les états généraux
de la lutte contre les maltraitances
c'est un fil rouge sur l'ensemble de du
portefeuille dont j'ai la responsabilité
de pouvoir lutter contre ces
maltraitances je précise également par
ailleurs que la qualité et la sécurité
d'accueil étant notre première des prix
et notre première priorité les pas
question de laisser ouvert des crèches
ou des places d'accueil en cas de manque
de professionnels nous avons demandé la
première ministre l'a demandé l'été
dernier à l'ensemble des préfets de
pouvoir faire mes des crèches en cas de
manque de professionnels dans ces
crèches j'aurai également à coeur de
mettre en oeuvre les 39 propositions qui
ont été faites par les inspecteurs
généraux des affaires sociales dans le
cas de la mise en place de la garantie
d'accueil du jeune enfant
vous venez de parler 39 propositions
formulées dans le rapport de Ligas c'est
certes vrai quand vous dites a été
hétérogénéité pardon dans les services
dans le service public ou dans les
services privés n'oubliez pas que les
normes EN quality de personnels ne sont
pas les mêmes dans les crèches privées
que dans les chèvres crèches publiques
les normes ne sont pas les mêmes et vous
savez bien que le personnel et la
dépense essentielle dans le
fonctionnement d'une crèche nous avons
besoin d'acte monsieur le ministre pas
d'intention vague et son calendrier il
est temps de mettre en place un
véritable service public de la petite
enfance
la parole est à notre collègue
Christophe André François pour le groupe
des Républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président ma question
s'adresse madame la ministre des
Affaires étrangères même la ministre il
y a deux ans jour pour jour le 10 mai
2021 notre compatriote Juan Rémy quinolo
a été arrêté à Bangui par les autorités
centrafricaines pour de prétendues
atteintes à la sécurité intérieure de
l'État complot et espionnage notre
compatriote a été maintenue dans un
premier temps en détention provisoire ce
qui a légitimement provoqué des tensions
entre la France et la Centrafrique
désormais en liberté provisoire et sous
le coup d'une enquête judiciaire qui
s'éternise et pour dubuesque fait
d'espionnage notre compatriote est
hébergé par l'ambassadeur de France dont
je tiens ici à souligner et à saluer
l'implication dans l'aide et le soutien
qui lui apporte
a entamé une greffe de la faim pour
dénoncer sa situation les allégations
fantaisistes portées contre notre
compatriotes ne peuvent en aucun cas
constituer le fondement d'une enquête
judiciaire sérieuse et même si la France
appelle à sa libération immédiate la
situation hélas n'évolue pas la
situation de notre compatriotes relève à
bien des égards du groupe de travail de
l'Organisation des Nations Unies sur la
détention arbitraire il est désormais
l'otage de Bangui dans une relation
délétère entre la France et la
Centrafrique rien de plus nous ne
pouvons pas l'accepter ce triste
anniversaire doit être le dernier et la
France doit tout mettre en œuvre pour
que Juan Rémy quinolo retrouve sa
liberté et son pays
pour vous répondre la parole étoffe
ministre délégué en charge notamment des
Français de l'étranger monsieur le
ministre merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Madame et messieurs les
sénateurs monsieur le sénateur fera ça
je vous remercie de votre question et
voici ce que je peux vous répondre à ce
stade avec toutes les précautions qui
conviennent dans cette situation et
j'espère que vous le comprendrez vous
l'avez dit effectivement monsieur rémi
quignolo a été arrêté qui a Bangui le en
mai 2021 il a été incarcéré en
République centrafricaine et dans le cas
d'une détention provisoire a été détenue
plus de 16 mois
la justice centrafricaine a décidé le 28
septembre 2022 de sa mise en liberté
provisoire afin qu'il puisse recevoir
les soins médicaux nécessaire dans
l'attente de son procès ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que durant sa détention
provisoire ce quinolo a bénéficié de ce
qu'on appelle la protection consulaire
prévue par la convention de Vienne du 23
avril
1963 et il a reçu à ce titre un certain
nombre de visites consulaires cette
situation continue d'être suivie qui a
quotidiennement à la fois à Bangui et à
Paris et les services du Quai d'Orsay
sont en relation étroite avec la famille
ils suivent la situation et nous
espérons évidemment une résolution
rapide de cette situation merci
Monsieur François
merci votre réponse ministre moi ce que
je veux juste c'est que Monsieur quinolo
sa famille sache que loin de Bangui il y
a des gens qui s'occupent de lui se
préoccupe de lui et mettre tout en
oeuvre pour qu'il revienne vers les
siens le plus rapidement possible merci
merci
la parole est à notre collègue souris
pour le groupe les républicains
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre depuis de nombreuses années
pour les fêtes de Pentecôte à neuvois
dans le Loiret des milliers de pèlerins
issus de la communauté des gens du
voyage provenant de la France entière
convergent vers 21 privés de
l'association Vie et Lumière en 2022 ils
étaient plus de 30 000 et depuis le 6
mai dernier ils sont plus de 40 000
voyageurs dans une commune de 1200
habitants au sein d'un bassin de vie de
25000 personnes autour de la petite
ville de Gien faute de place des gens du
voyage
occupent illégalement des terrains
agricoles branche leurs installations
électriques et d'eau directement chez
des particuliers et les alentours
devenant un véritable cloaque son jaugés
d'immondis dont tout genre de fortes
tensions sont en train d'éclater entre
les habitants excédés et des gens du
voyage cette situation pose de graves
problèmes de sécurité de salubrité et de
santé publique d'autant que les urgences
de Gien sont fermées jusqu'au mois de
septembre prochain faute de personnel
aucun des services publics les
dimensions pour un tel aff jusqu'à
maintenant les huit lus acceptaient le
principe d'un unique rassemblement dès
lors que celui-ci respectait les
capacités du terrain soient 20000
personnes ce n'est plus le cas et depuis
quelques années un deuxième
rassemblement de niveau européen est
organisé en août en 2015 les élus locaux
et les parlementaires dont nos collègues
sueurs et Cardou avait déjà alerté le
Premier ministre lequel c'était engagé à
ce que l'État propose dorénavant un
autre lieu pour un deuxième
rassemblement annuel la promesse fut
respectée pendant quelques années mais
elle nuque un temps depuis les élus ont
été promenés dans les différents
ministères et ont été reçus par
plusieurs premiers ministres enfin
l'ensemble des habitants en subissent au
quotidien nuisance et incivilités et la
commune de nevoye demeure isolée madame
la ministre pouvez-vous premièrement
faire respecter la parole de l'État et
deuxièmement comptez-vous faire preuve
d'autorité pour enfin reprendre le
contrôle de cette situation inadmissible
[Musique]
pour vous répondre la parole est à
madame la ministre déléguée en charge
des collectivités territoriales madame
Faure
le Président Mesdames et le dessinateurs
monsieur le sénateur sourit j'entends et
j'ai bien conscience des difficultés de
la problématique que vous soulevez le
rassemblement de nos voix et je le sais
pour avoir échangé avec Anthony Dubois
revêt une importance toute particulière
pour les gens du voyage se rassemblement
évangélique qui se déroule à neuvois du
6 au 14 mai devrait accueillir environ
20 000 personnes il se réunit
aujourd'hui avec plus de 40 000
personnes comme vous l'avez indiquées
dans une commune de 1200 habitants et
fait peser sur cette commune et les
services de l'État une très forte
contrainte je tenais à saluer
l'implication des élus et des services
de l'État pour que cet événement se
déroule dans les meilleures conditions
cette surf fréquentation pose de réels
problèmes en termes d'installation des
gens du voyage sur des terrains non
prévus à cet effet en termes de
circulation en termes sanitaire sur ces
aspects la préfète du Loiret le
gouvernement ont pris des mesures fortes
dans l'optique d'un second rassemblement
au mois d'août j'entends les inquiétudes
dériverains et des élus et le
gouvernement est pleinement mobilisé sur
ce sujet je m'engage à ce que l'ensemble
des parties prenant bienvenue aux
associations d'élus association Vie et
Lumière soit associée pour dégager des
solutions pérennes pour les années à
venir dans le respect des sensibilités
de chacun je vous remercie monsieur
sorry aime la ministre je constate que
vous n'apportez aucune solution concrète
pour le deuxième rassemblement le
gouvernement le gouvernement fuit ses
responsabilités abandonnent et livre à
eux-mêmes les habitants de nevoye ainsi
vous actez la totale d'émission de
l'État pour protéger ses citoyens
[Applaudissements]
merci mon cher collègues
les prochaines questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement auront lieu mercredi 17 mai
merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres je
vais suspendre la séance sera reprise à
16h30 pour l'attribution des
prérogatives d'une commission d'enquête
à la commission des finances et pour les
explications de vote puis le vote sur le
projet de loi ratifiant les ordonnances
relatives à la partie législative du
livre 7 du code monétaire et financier
et portant diverses dispositions
relatives à l'Outre-mer la séance est
suspendue
[Musique]
voilà pour cette séance des questions
d'actualité au Gouvernement du Sénat que
vous avez pu suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur notre antenne parmi les
temps forts aujourd'hui on retiendra cet
échange autour de la manifestation de
l'ultra-droite autorisée sanitaire à
Paris et l'indignation des sénateurs de
gauche écouter un extrait de la question
du socialiste David hassouline
nous avons été choqué que vous ayez
laissé se dérouler manifestation non
loin d'ici en plein Paris à la veille de
la commémoration de la Libération
du Jong nazi en Europe avec des
organisateurs et des participants dont
des proches de Marine Le Pen qui
menaçaient des journalistes des badauds
qui se réclament de l'idéologie nazie et
pétaniste qui appelle à abattre la
République et qui à peine explicitement
à la haine raciste et antisémite et le
sénateur socialiste d'ajouter qu'il
était stupéfait je cite que des préfets
et des ministres et justifiés se laisser
faire et de réclamer la dissolution du
guide le groupe d'union défense qui
défilait avec leur drapeau noir écouter
un extrait de la réponse de la
secrétaire des tâches de la struente
Sonia bac S la main du gouvernement de
manière solidaire ne tremble pas quand
il s'agit de combattre l'ultra droite ce
sont d'ailleurs 12 groupuscules dissous
en 5 ans en 5 ans qui portait des
messages à caractère raciste antisémites
ou homophobe qui ont été dissous ce sont
plusieurs manifestations du droit droit
qui ont été interdites ces derniers mois
à Lyon à Montpellier à Paris et ce sera
encore dimanche prochain une
manifestation en hommage à Jeanne d'Arc
dans A opéra porté par des groupuscules
d'ultra-droites qui sera interdite par
la par la Préfecture de Police vous
venez de l'entendre cette annonce
IFSI dans le Sénat tout à l'heure cette
manifestation hommage à Jeanne d'Arc à
Opéra ce dimanche 14 mai qui va être
interdite à annoncer la secrétaire
d'État mais la secrétaire d'État qui n'a
pas répondu directement à débit
d'insuline sur une une possible
dissolution du guide Tam merci merci
beaucoup Quentin pour ce débrief des
questions au gouvernement et tout de
suite on va rejoindre Alexandre qui se
trouve salle des pour toutes les
réactions politiques qui ont commencé
avec le président du groupe LR au Sénat
Bruno retaillod
et bien le Sénat va voter normalement
vraisemblablement en faveur de la
création d'une commission d'enquête
bonjour Bruno Retailleau bonjour à vous
en faveur de la création d'une
commission d'enquête sur l'affaire du
fond Marianne je le rappelle c'est ce
fond créé par le gouvernement 2021 après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty pour lutter
contre la radicalisation en ligne et se
font Marianne est suspecté d'avoir été
mal utilisé notamment par certaines
associations à des fins politiques la
création de cette commission d'enquête
c'est une décision importante de la part
de la Haute Assemblée bien sûr mais ça
répond aussi à notre métier à nos
devoirs c'est à dire que on vote la loi
mais on contrôle l'action du
Gouvernement je voudrais simplement dire
que sur ce thème là j'ai entendu
d'ailleurs le ministre Attal sur le
thème de la fraude on doit vérifier
l'usage des fonds publics on est le pays
au monde en tout cas dans le monde
développé où on a le plus d'impôts on a
le plus de prélèvements et on a le plus
de dépenses publiques pensez bien que
sur un fond qui en plus avait été
rentrer dans des circonstances qui
étaient particulières je vous rappelle
que c'est après la décapitation de
Samuel Paty il y a une exigence une
exigence de contrôle pour savoir comment
c'est font qui sont des fonds publics
ont été utilisés si il y a pas un risque
que cette commission d'enquête sur le
travail du parquet national financier
qui a aussi ouvert une enquête bien sûr
vous savez qu'on avait ouvert cette
enquête en tout cas la perspective de
l'enquête on l'avait annoncé avant la
décision du PNF il faut pas qu'il y ait
de recouvrement c'est normal il y a le
place du juge d'un côté de l'autorité
judiciaire et puis de l'autre côté du
Parlement on a coutume c'était passé au
moment de l'affaire Benalla il y avait
eu aussi une enquête et les choses
avaient pu prospérer d'un côté comme de
l'autre c'est ce qu'on fera une fois de
plus donc la séparation des pouvoirs
sera respectée on va parler
d'immigration Bruno Retailleau puisque
le gouvernement devait reporter à
l'automne son projet de loi sur
l'immigration et finalement et bien il
lance des consultations des
parlementaires pour présenter le texte
en juillet est-ce que la droite
sénatoriale a certaines conditions
pourraient au final voter ce projet de
loi récupération pour présenter le texte
en conseil des ministres mais un texte
qui viendrait à l'automne c'est-à-dire
un an après que le ministre d'intérieur
mais moi appelé c'était à la fin du mois
d'août dernier était dernier en disant
mais on va passer dès le début du mois
d'octobre 2022 ce texte on en est je
crois au 3 ou 4e rapport le prison de
République il y a quelques semaines
avait annoncé qu'il y aura un texte
l'été ensuite qui serait sauditionné et
maintenant nous annonce à nouveau un
texte on s'y retrouve plus c'est quelque
chose qui tient je trouve du gag voilà
nous en tout cas on a proposé nos textes
il y a deux textes que nous déposerons
ensemble d'un commun accord ici au Sénat
et avec nos collègues de l'Assemblée
nationale nos collègues LR et je crois
que c'est l'information que le
gouvernement a eu du dépôt de cet axe
qui ont amené le gouvernement à répondre
parce que un des problèmes majeurs qu'on
a en France que ce soit d'ailleurs dans
les outre-mer Mayotte la situation de
Mayotte mais aussi dans la France
métropolitaine regarder avec les mineurs
non accompagnés qu'on appelait autrefois
les mineurs isolés la situation d'un
département proche de l'Italie comme les
Alpes-Maritimes c'est le chaos
migratoire donc c'est un problème qui
est urgent qu'il faut régler évidemment
alors qu'elles vont être les mesures
fortes dans ces deux textes des
parlementaires la République il y a de
texte une ordinaire
vous retrouverez un certain nombre de
points qu'on a déjà voté par exemple la
transformation de l'aide médicale d'État
parce que c'est la gaji en net médical
d'urgence pour restreindre le palier de
soins bien d'autres dispositions aussi
puis il y aura un texte de loi
constitutionnelle et justement sur ce
texte constitutionnel dernière question
est-ce que vous avez proposé de toucher
au droit du sol en touchera en tout cas
à la possibilité d'article 11 d'avoir
dans le champ du référendum législatif
évidemment la question migratoire ça me
paraît être important voilà référendum
sur l'immigration proposée par les
républicains merci beaucoup merci à
Bruno Retailleau d'être venu au micro de
Public Sénat merci merci beaucoup
Alexandre pour cette première réaction
et on va enchaîner les réactions sales
des conférences lors de ce débrief des
questions au gouvernement car à présent
Alexandre vous allez revenir sur la
séquence qui portait tout à l'heure sur
la réforme du lycée professionnel et
vous êtes avec Carole Grandjean la
ministre chargée de l'enseignement et de
la formation professionnelle
effectivement bonjour Carole Grandjean
bonjour alors il y a eu plusieurs
questions sur la réforme du lycée
professionnel cet après-midi dans la
séance de questions d'actualité d'abord
une question sur la forme c'est une
réforme qui est plutôt critiquée les
syndicats sont opposés est-ce que c'est
le moment de l'affaire alors que
l'exécutive veut apaiser le pays après
la réforme des retraites de nombreux
acteurs accompagnent cette réforme des
lycées professionnels tout simplement
parce que le constat est fait qu'un
certain nombre de jeunes sont en échec
dans la voie professionnelle non pas à
cause des enseignants et du lycée
professionnel mais il y a un taux
d'échec qui est important un taux de
décrochage un taux d'insertion
insuffisant de ton insertion
professionnelle insuffisant et ainsi
plutôt de poursuite d'études réussie
insuffisantes c'est pourquoi le
président de la République a annoncé la
semaine dernière sa volonté de réformer
le lycée professionnel engagement qu'il
avait pris lors de la campagne de 2022
et qu'il tient par ses annonces de
manière à préparer les compétences de
demain de ces jeunes les préparer à un
environnement professionnel dans lequel
ils vont évoluer tout au long de leur
carrière donc pour vous il y a urgence
il y a nécessité à faire cette réforme
alors sur le fond ce texte est bien il
va augmenter de 50% la durée des stages
des lycéens professionnels plutôt
orientés dans les secteurs en tension
est-ce que ça veut dire que l'objet de
cette réforme c'est aussi de répondre à
des besoins économiques des besoins des
entreprises cette réforme elle vise à
préparer les compétences dont les la
nation aura besoin donc à préparer les
grandes transitions celle du numérique
celle de la transition énergétique
écologique sous ces transitions aussi
démographiques notamment liées au métier
du soin mais c'est aussi bien sûr
répondre aux enjeux économiques mais
c'est surtout préparer des jeunes cette
un tiers de la jeunesse française qui
passe par le lycée professionnel c'est
620 000 jeunes chaque année qui sont en
lycée professionnel et nous retrouvons
au lycée professionnel
trois fois plus de décrocheurs que dans
l'enseignement général c'est un taux
d'insertion qui est assez faible puisque
un élève sur deux n'arrive pas à
s'insérer malgré l'obtention de son
diplôme et heure poursuites d'études et
que seul un élève sur deux qui poursuit
les études réussit à les aller à les
obtenir donc c'est un vrai sujet nous ne
pouvons pas continuer à laisser des
jeunes s'engager dans une voie dans
laquelle il ne réussissent pas c'est
notre responsabilité de pouvoir
effectivement accompagner aussi bien les
fragilités de ces élèves de ce niveau
scolaire qui parfois leur rend difficile
sa scolarité mais aussi les préparer à
des compétences qu'ils pourront mettre
en avant et valoriser ces stages que
vous ayez évoqués et qui vont augmenter
en terminale vont les conduire aussi
avoir plus d'expérience professionnelle
à faire valoir aussi une connaissance du
milieu professionnel qui sera aidant
pour pouvoir s'insérer dans dans
l'emploi c'est vraiment un des enjeux
cette année de terminale qui sera
évolutive selon le projet du jeûne soit
en augmentant le temps de stage parce
que le jeune veut s'insérer dans
l'emploi et on voit à quel point
l'augmentation du volume de stage en fin
d'année qui leur permet ensuite de
basculer directement vers un emploi va
être aidant pour s'insérer ou alors de
revenir au mois de juin préparer sur 4
semaines la poursuite d'études et là
aussi vu le taux de décrochage en
enseignement supérieur c'est essentiel
de bien les préparer pour qu'il
réussisse dans la poursuite d'études
merci beaucoup Merci à VOUS Grandjean
pour votre réaction micro de public
c'est normal merci merci beaucoup on va
commencer à faire le débrief de cette
séance de questions au gouvernement en
plateau et pour cela j'ai le plaisir
d'accueillir Christine lamarde bonjour
bonjour vous êtes sénatrice les
républicains des Hauts-de-Seine et
vice-présidente de la Commission des
finances face à vous Mélanie Vogel
bonjour C'est natrice écologiste
représentant les Français établis hors
de France et enfin Pierre-Jean de laine
bonjour vous êtes sénateurs les
indépendants de laine et pour commencer
je vous propose que l'on parle du fond
Marianne puisque d'ici trois quatre
minutes maintenant et bien a priori le
Sénat devrait valider en séance publique
un voter pour la proposition de
résolution qui crée cette commission
d'enquête Christine lavard on va pas
forcément mettre la charrue avant les
deux mais on l'a dit il y a pas beaucoup
de suspense vous êtes satisfait déjà
qu'il y ait eu et bien la validation par
la commission des lois ce matin la
validation hier par la Conférence des
Présidents ce n'était pas si évident
compte tenu de l'ouverture d'une
information judiciaire par le parquet
national financier et enfin cette
question elle était mise en lumière par
le président de la commission des
finances Claude rénal qui effectivement
est le premier qui a exposé des
questionnements sur l'utilisation du
fond Marianne merci de révélation de la
presse exactement donc finalement le
gouvernement est gardé son en venant
demander à la justice de se saisir du
dossier a aussi essayé je pense de se
défendre enfin de montrer qu'ils étaient
voilà
en ouvrant en fait une procédure
judiciaire ça réduit en fait le
périmètre d'un vestigation qui va que va
être le vôtre
entre les deux procédures et tout ce qui
est couvert par le change judiciaire ne
pourra pas être couvert par la
commission d'enquête et vous craignez
que du coup votre travail soit plus
compliqué puisque je rappelle que sa
commission des finances qui se dote des
pouvoirs d'une commission d'enquête en
espèces effectivement le fait qu'il y
ait cette procédure judiciaire qui soit
ouverte va venir restreindre le
périmètre sur lequel va pouvoir
travailler la commission des finances
oui c'est donc il y a quand même un vrai
problème dans cette commission d'enquête
en tout cas dans son champ
d'investigation pour l'instant mais la
limogel qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
ce qui a été dit est vrai effectivement
là séparation des pouvoirs doit être
respectée donc le Sénat ne peut pas
interférer avec autorité exactement
néanmoins c'est quand même très utile
d'avoir cette commission d'enquête
personnellement je m'en réjouis Marlène
Schiappa et d'autres personnes qui vont
être amenées à être convoqué par les
sénateurs et sénatrices qui en seront
membres vont devoir venir témoigner sous
serment donc tout serment on a plutôt
intérêt à dire la vérité et ils vont
être interrogés sur le fond on a entendu
la défense de Marlène Schiappa nous
expliquer qu'en fait
c'était pas ses amis
et que c'était la principale finalement
le principal argument qu'elle a sorti
qu'elle n'était pas amie avec eux bon
c'est pas c'est parce qu'intéresse le
soir Marianne
c'est une un fond qui a été créé à la
suite de l'assassinat de Samuel il a
pour objectif de soutenir des
associations pour promouvoir des valeurs
républicaines combattre les discours
séparatistes il est doté de 2,5 millions
d'euros et il a été réparti entre 17
structures il y a deux structures qui
posent problème et la plus grosse
300000 € de chacune venez juste d'être
créé voilà
et l'autre donc n'avait aucune enfin
c'est extrêmement
étrange que on choisit cette structure
là sans aucune histoire et l'autre
n'avait aucune compétence dans le champ
en question et aujourd'hui Marlène
Chapman nous a juste dit non arrêtez de
dire que c'est mes amis c'est pas mes
amis bon moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
pas de savoir
leur lien d'amitié est-ce qu'ils vont
brancher ensemble le dimanche c'est pas
ça la question la question c'est comment
est-ce qu'on a pu distribuer des fonds
publics dans un contexte en plus
extrêmement lourd extrêmement grave ou
un professeur a été décapité 10 ans que
c'était pour lutter contre la
radicalisation et les distribuer à des
structures qui n'ont rien à voir et qui
ont produit en plus bon du contenu qui
avait plutôt visiblement comme objectif
contre les hommes politiques
d'Emmanuel Macron donc elle devra s'en
expliquer
quel est le rapport avec la lutte contre
la radicalisation on ça pose vraiment
question piège en versement sur
l'utilisation des fonds publics on parle
de 2,5 millions d'euros et effectivement
quand même un cas qui a frappé toute la
France symboliquement extrêmement fort
l'assassinata lymphatie mais on parle
d'argent public donc qui est de la
transparence qui est une commission
d'enquête c'est tout à fait logique
après faut pas faire semblant de
découvrir le soleil je veux dire à
l'échelle nationale et à toutes les
échelles locales des associations des
structures des comités des organisations
qui sont suivantées qui font un vrai
travail sur le terrain et que de temps
en temps au fond de la politique ça
existe c'est c'est c'est même
c'est-à-dire consubstantiel à
l'existence des associations
ce qu'il faut voir ça vous choquerait
pas quelque chose qui font beaucoup de
travail sur le terrain et qui de temps
en temps à certains moments prennent des
positions politiques ça existe ce qu'il
faut regarder sur ce sujet là c'est
est-ce que c'est structures ont été
créées purement et simplement pour faire
de la politique ou alors est-ce qu'il y
a eu des vrais actions et que dans ces
associations il y en a un ou deux qui
ont pris des positions c'est ça qu'il
faut éclaircir et c'est tout à fait
logique que la commission d'enquête
travaille dessus l'important de lancer
cette commission d'enquête et d'ailleurs
on va rejoindre Quentin dans l'hémicycle
du Sénat car le vote vient d'avoir lieu
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé Quentin
voilà c'est la séance qui vient d'être
reprise Pierre Laurent qui siège ici au
plateau il vient d'avoir un vote à main
levée et
l'unanimité des votants ici en séance et
bien le Sénat a bien doté la commission
des finances des pouvoirs d'une
commission d'enquête pour une durée de 3
mois avec un intitulé Tam c'est très
important qui est celui qui avait été
initialement proposé c'est à dire un
intitulé et une commission d'enquête sur
la création du fond Marianne la
sélection des projets et l'attribution
des subventions le contrôle de leur
exécution et les résultats obtenus au
regard des objectifs du fond c'est donc
cette intitulé qui a été conservée et on
le rappelle effectivement il y avait
cette proposition de commission
d'enquête depuis le 24 avril un Claude
Reynal Ken avait fait la demande au nom
de la commission des finances et donc
c'est maintenant officiel les pouvoirs
d'une commission d'enquête ont été
donnés à la commission des finances à
l'instant merci merci beaucoup Quentin
et à ce propos et bien on va rejoindre
Alexandre Poussard salle des conférences
pour l'interview de Rachid temal Rachid
temal qui est là des premiers groupes
socialistes à avoir réclamé cette
commission d'enquête
le Sénat lance cet après-midi la
commission d'enquête sur l'affaire du
fond Marianne le fond gouvernemental
lancé en 2021 après l'assassinat de
Samuel Paty pour lutter contre la
radicalisation en ligne se font des
suspecté d'avoir été mal utilisés par
certaines associations notamment à des
fins politiques vous faisiez partie des
premiers parlementaires à demander cette
investigation parlementaire donc c'est
plutôt une victoire pour le Sénat
aujourd'hui je pense c'est surtout une
victoire pour la démocratie la
transparence et la vérité d'abord nous
le devons à la famille de Samuel Paty
parce que vous l'avez rappelé il était
il était professeur du et puis il
habitait dans la loi c'est là où était
assassiné dans un attentat et c'est vrai
que c'était une bonne chose qu'un fond
Marianne puisse aider à la lutte sur la
contre la légalisation sur les réseaux
sociaux je trouvais ça bien et puis on
se rend compte effectivement on l'a vu
le travail de la presse qui a fait un
excellent travail sur ce qui s'en est
passé et c'est vrai que moi j'étais au
Sénat le premier à déposer avec mon
groupe une demande de commission
d'enquête le président Claude Raynal la
reprise notamment via la commission des
finances qui se transforment et donc le
Sénat vote cette commission skate c'est
une victoire je pense importante je le
dis pour la démocratie pour la
transparence et encore une fois pour la
mémoire de Samuel Paty alors le parking
national financier a aussi ouvert une
information judiciaire sur cette affaire
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas un risque tout
simplement que l'enquête parlementaire
empiète sur le travail judiciaire non je
crois que Claude Reynal et les membres
de la commission des finances seront
être dans leur dans leur champ et non
pas celui effectivement du de l'enquête
du PNF souvenez-vous que au moment de
l'affaire Benalla où il y avait aussi
une enquête qui avait été lancée donc là
moi je sais que le Sénat sera mon est en
quête cette commission d'enquête
jusqu'au bout encore une fois sans
marcher sur les plates bandes de la
justice et la justice fera et doit faire
son travail mais là il s'agirait
effectivement d'entendre auditionner de
sur les documents qui ont déjà été
transmis à la commission des finances
qui montrent qu'effectivement au moins
il y a deux associations qui posent
problème je rappelle la première où on
s'interroge sur l'efficacité du travail
S0 regarde du financement et puis sur la
seconde la seconde le fait que la cette
association là pendant une campagne
présidentielle
a taper des candidats notamment je pense
à hindelgo et donc ça permettait aussi
de favoriser un autre contact s'appelle
Emmanuel Macron donc je ne suis pas en
train de dire que Macron est concerné
loin de là sont faux mais il est clair
que la mise de l'époque Marlène Schiappa
doit maintenant répondre
l'administration qui a porté cela doit
également répondre et c'est le travail
que doit mener aujourd'hui le Sénat et
au moment où on sait qu'il y a une crise
de démocratie de pays une interrogation
et citoyens sur l'action publique je
crois que c'est important justement le
Sénat puisse faire ce travail là en
toute transparence alors dans cette
commission d'enquête il y aura des
sénateurs les républicains des sénateurs
de gauche finalement beaucoup de
ceintures d'opposition finalement au
gouvernement est-ce que c'est un
investigation parlementaire elle ne va
pas être aussi politique vous savez si
je devais la répondre quand le contexte
un texte fondamental est adopté par le
Sénat est-ce que il est remis en cause
parce que beaucoup de gens demandent de
l'opposition ont voté ce texte là la
réponse est non faut pas faire ce procès
attention je veux dire vous savez bien
que au Sénat nous avons ce travail là
cette capacité à travailler en toute
transparence les documents et les
résultats seront rendus publics parce
que je rappelle que avant au bout des
trois mois donc on va dire ami juillet
il y aura un rapport de la commission
enquête qui sera rendu qui sera transmis
au bureau du Sénat et c'est le bureau
c'est d'acide devait avoir ensuite des
choses à dire ou à faire qui prendra les
décisions de haut et bien je crois que
nous savons très bien qu'une commission
d'enquête qui est normée qui reconnue
par la caution sera réalisé dans je veux
dire dans la totale transparence dont la
garantie des choses parce que
rappelez-vous vous avez aussi des
membres de la commission des membres du
groupe de la majorité de présidentielle
qui sont dans cette commission là les
débats seront publiques puisque les
sénateurs pourront participer donc je
n'ai aucune crainte et je le redis
encore une fois quand un texte a adopté
il y a aussi des gens de droite des gens
de gauche ça devrait pas en cause le
texte merci merci beaucoup
de Public Sénat merci Alexandre voilà
pour cette interview de Rachid temal et
pendant que nous sommes ensemble sur ce
plateau on va aussi regarder et bien les
images on voit et bien Elisabeth borne
Gérard Larcher Yaël brune pivée mais
aussi Jean-Marc Ayraud qui sont présents
actuellement dans le jardin du
Luxembourg la première ministre
président de la cérémonie de la Journée
nationale des mémoires de la traite de
l'esclavage et de leurs abolitions dans
le jardin du Luxembourg et là lui est
présenté et bien le panneau d'exposition
consacré à tout ça l'ouverture voilà
cette commémoration
annuelle qui a lieu donc chaque année
dans le jardin du Luxembourg on va y
revenir à la fin de cette émission mais
encore une question tout de même sur le
fond Marianne Christine Lavarde on a
entendu beaucoup on a entendu
Jean-François Claude Rennes allait être
assez prudent surtout pas dire il y a
une affaire Marlène Schiappa etc on sent
aussi que le Sénat ne veut pas avoir un
procès qui lui soit fait par l'exécutif
de commission d'enquête qui serait
politique on se rappelle comment ça
s'était passé sur l'affaire Benalla et
où et bien ça avait été extrêmement
conflictuel entre l'exécutif et le Sénat
exactement et il faut reconnaître que
nous avons attendu déjà d'avoir enfin on
n'a pas tout de suite dit oui à
l'instauration de la commission
d'enquête il s'avère que le président de
la commission des finances utilisant les
pouvoirs qui lui sont conférés dans un
premier temps demandé des documents qui
ont qui ont été transmis dans les délins
partis faut quand même le souligner
parce que c'est assez rare d'avoir les
documents dans les délais imparti quand
on demande quelque chose au gouvernement
et il s'avère que à l'étude de ces
documents est ressorti que deux
associations avaient bénéficié d'une
part substantielle du fond sans qu'on
puisse enfin ce que disait très bien
Madame vosgel tout à l'heure établir un
lien entre les sommes versées le
l'activité l'association et l'objet du
fond donc il dès lors il y avait lieu en
fait de pousser l'investigation et
pousser l'investigation dans les outils
qui sont à notre disposition
effectivement c'est la commission
d'enquête qui nous permet d'aller plus
loin possible voilà donc les travaux de
la Commission dans 4 devrait débuter fin
mai avec un certain nombre d'auditions
bien sûr à suivre sur public snow autre
autant fort lors de cette séance de
questions au Gouvernement compta en
parler tout à l'heure et bien la
séquence qui a été consacrée aux
manifestations de l'ultra droite qui ont
été la manifestation notamment à Paris
qui a été autorisé ce week-end et depuis
et bien le gouvernement a dit demandait
au préfet interdiction de toute
manifestation de l'ultra-droite écouter
la séquence tout à l'heure dans
l'hémicycle
nous avons été choqués que vous ayez
laissé se dérouler manifestation non
loin d'ici en plein Paris à la veille de
la commémoration de la Libération
du Jong nazi en Europe avec des
organisateurs et des participants dont
des proches de Marine Le Pen qui
menaçaient des journalistes des badauds
qui se réclament de l'idéologie nazie et
pétainiste qui appelle à abattre la
République et qui appelle explicitement
à la haine raciste et antisémite la main
du gouvernement de manière solidaire ne
tremble pas quand il s'agit de combattre
l'ultra-droite ce sont d'ailleurs douze
groupuscules dissous en 5 ans en 5 ans
qui portait des messages à caractère
raciste antisémite ou homophobe qui ont
été dissous ce sont plusieurs
manifestations d'une trois droites qui
ont été interdites ces derniers mois à
Lyon à Montpellier à Paris et ce sera
encore dimanche prochain une
manifestation en hommage à Jeanne d'Arc
dans A opéra porté par des groupuscules
d'ultra-droites qui sera interdite par
la par la préfecture de police
mais la niveauja la gauche il y en a
beaucoup qui ont dénoncé un deux poids
de mesure ce week-end d'une part et bien
les casseroles pour protester contre la
réforme des retraites interdite mais pas
les symboles néo-nazis est-ce que et
bien cette sortie de Gérald Darmanin qui
dit maintenant interdire donc c'est
manifestations est un pour vous la
polémique non parce que déjà le passage
que vous venez de montrer je trouvais
très très symbolique la ministre
s'utilise trois fois le terme David
hassouline parle à juste titre de
rassemblement qui ceux qui promouvent
l'idéologie nazie il se balade avec des
des croiss Celtes ils sont ce sont des
néonazis des néophéistes c'est pas
l'ultra droite le gouvernement refuse
d'utiliser les termes qui sont les bons
et pour vous
parce que ça finalement ça des diabolise
c'est on dit pas néo-nazi quand on dit
néo-nation on comprend quand même qu'il
y a un gros problème
ultra droite on dit même plus extrême
droite on dit ultra droite qui est un
terme moi je ne sais pas à quoi ça fait
référence exactement et donc ça c'est un
problème le deuxième problème
effectivement c'est que c'est vrai que
garantir les libertés publiques garantir
la liberté de manifester c'est pas
toujours facile parce que parfois et
bien ça nécessite de garantir la liberté
de manifester tout le monde voilà mais
il y a des cadres il y a un cadre
notamment le fait d'inciter à la haine
et normalement un cadre qui permet
d'interdire et le fait de d'être un
trouble à l'heure de public or on a un
gouvernement qui considère que une
manifestation de néo-nazis
ça ne pose pas de troubles à l'heure de
public mais que des casseroles oui et là
on a quand même un sujet on a quand même
un sujet alors il nous explique oui mais
vous comprenez c'est très compliqué les
arrêter d'interdiction après ils sont
cassés dissoudre des mouvements c'est
très compliqué très bien mais
bizarrement tous ces arguments ne sont
pas valables pour interdire des
manifestations avec des casseroles qui
sont les arrêter sont aussi cassés deux
jours après dissoudre le mouvement des
soulèvements de la terre qui est
juridiquement ça ne veut rien dire de
dissoudre ce mouvement parce que on peut
pas le dissoudre mais là ça peut être
présent notamment lors des
manifestations de sainte Soline etc et
en fait
quelle est la cohérence là dedans et je
considère malgré tout que le danger pour
la République le danger pour la
démocratie qui rampant dans l'Europe
entière passait plus le néonazisme que
les soulèvements de la terre qui veulent
interdire les bassines Pierre-Jean
verzelen qu'en penser est-ce que le
gouvernement a fait du poids de mesure
ce week-end avant et bien finalement de
changer de pied bon déjà les images
auxquelles on a assisté je veux dire le
défilé de gens billets tout en noir avec
des cagoule avec des croix gammées enfin
ça fait juste pendant le dos en fait bon
est-ce que le gouvernement les amis sur
un pied d'égalité je pense pas est-ce
qu'ils ont fait une erreur de panne
interdire la réponse c'est oui et
visiblement même ils l'ont ils l'ont
reconnu mais je je je en tout cas de mon
point de vue il y a aucune c'est pas du
tout sur le même plan même si j'ai pas
voté le décalage de l'âge de la retraite
et la réforme de la retraite telle
qu'elle était présentée les casseroles
par exemple plus ça passe plus ça me
gonfle il m'a fait évidemment que ça n'a
rien à voir alors que les casseroles
sont interdites
le président de la République
absolument logique bon mais après qu'on
ait le droit de taper dans les
casseroles dans la rue ça me pose pas de
ça me pose pas de difficulté il y a ce
sujet des néo-nazies et de l'ultra
droite quand même il y a ces
manifestations qui se font avec je pense
le terme de l'ultra gauche est bon mais
en tout cas beaucoup de violence et on a
un pays qui manifeste beaucoup en ce
moment et dans lesquels on le cerveau
beaucoup de violence et ça c'est le
signe d'une république qui va pas très
bien et du fait qu'il y en a beaucoup
qui ne savent plus qu'on vit dans une
république et d'où vient cette violence
pour vous est-ce que il y a pas aussi
une crise peut-être institutionnelle une
crise avec le gouvernement qu'est-ce qui
se passe
comme beaucoup je le je peux le
comprendre évidemment de la casser le
bien des autres il y a une question qui
a été posée par Jean-Pierre Grand du
coup les indépendants sur les
commerçants qui seront cassés les
vitrines mais là c'est profondément
inexcusable profondément une excusable
et d'ailleurs mais ça c'est un vrai
sujet qu'il faudra avoir un jour c'est
qu'on sait qui sont les gens qui
commettent ces méfaits l'idée c'est
qu'elle ne puisse pas accéder aux
manifestations donc ça demande qu'on
puisse les incinérer résidence depuis
des empêcher de venir elles vont
qu'elles commettent les méfaits mais ça
c'est un vrai sujet qui va falloir se
poser
par le Conseil constitutionnel on sait
que c'est une difficulté et
c'est un peu ce sujet aussi là qui se
pose celui de la liberté de manifester
versus et bien et le trouble à l'ordre
public et les incitations à la haine
raciale Christina effectivement parce
que la réponse que Gérald Darmanin a
fait hier à l'Assemblée nationale
interrogée sur le même sujet était plus
précise enfin différentes dans sa nature
que la réponse de Sonia bacasse et il
indiqué qu'en fait là demande qui avait
été déposée en préfecture avait été
faite par une personne seule donc en
tant que tel la demande faite ne
n'indiquez pas que ce serait un défilé
de personnes habillées en noir portant
donc oui et il a rappelé aussi que en
ayant interdit une manifestation sur le
même motif quelques mois auparavant
trois mois ça avait été cassé donc
d'ailleurs la réponse qu'il a invité
c'était de venir modifier le droit
effectivement quand il dit ça ben
effectivement en modifiant droit mais là
où je rejoins aussi Jean-Pierre verzelen
c'est qu'aujourd'hui on parle de ces
manifestations qui posent problème mais
je tiens aussi à dire que les
manifestations d'écotérisme elle pose
aussi problème quand dimanche
au terrorisme je suis désolé quand on va
dans des forêts qu'on met des clous dans
les arbres pour que le moment où les
découpes seront faites les bûcherons se
trouvent avec des chênes qui cassent qui
met en leur vie en danger je suis désolé
on atteint aussi à la personne à
l'intégrité physique comme on atteint
parfois à l'intégrité des locaux donc il
faut enfin voilà aujourd'hui on a le
droit de manifester mais il faut aussi
savoir raison garder on est quand même
en train encore en train de glisser sur
le débat et aussi
dans un débat sur qu'est-ce qu'on fait
avec la montée de l'extrême droite et du
néo-nazisme en Europe et en France
soudainement on parle des écologistes
qui vont défendre la forêt donc je
trouve qu'il y a quand même un problème
dans le fait d'aborder la chose comme ça
par ailleurs sur la manifestation elle a
lieu tous les ans je veux dire jardin il
peut pas me dire qu'en fait il savait
pas ce que c'était cette manifestation
elle a lieu tous les ans c'est une
manifestation de néo-nazis qui a lieu
tous les ans et d'ailleurs il a même
utilisé ça comme argument
donc que du coup cette année on s'est
dit que pareil ça n'est pas possible
donc il peut pas raconter ah mais
c'était une personne seule du coup je
savais pas qu'ils allaient venir avec
des cagoule et des croix gammées bah en
fait c'est des cagoules et les croix
gamelle l'année dernière quoi c'était la
même manifestation par le même collectif
créé par le guide donc voilà il y a pas
de surprise d'ailleurs une question sur
la dissolution de le guide a été dissous
on voit voilà qu'il qu'il revient c'est
un peu le sujet sur toutes les
associations qu'on dissous et qui
reviennent qu'on sort par la porte et
qui reviennent par la fenêtre on voit
bien que la dissolution en soi n'est pas
la solution
alors je suis vraiment pas là pour
défendre le gouvernement mais dans ce
que vous dites ça laisse entendre le
côté le ministre de l'Intérieur a
quasiment laissé faire et évidemment que
évidemment que c'est pas le cas
évidemment qu'ils ont dû se retrouver
piégé et d'ailleurs il y a une réaction
au lendemain en disant ben écoutez
contact on acceptera plus du tout ce
genre de choses ensuite sur la
dissolution des associations mais ça
c'est une question qui se posera partout
de tous les côtés y compris sur les
associations echo Eco terroristes à
partir du moment où vous les dissolvez
les gens ils disparaissent pas les gens
ils restent bon et ils peuvent essayer
de se de se refonder de réexister bon de
manière légale ou pas bah ça c'est tout
le travail de la force de l'état des
empêcher de le faire donc quand il se
dit que la main du gouvernement ne
tremble pas et parle du nombre
d'associations dissoute on voit bien que
ce n'est pas forcément la solution
Christina barne non mais je pense que on
le disait tout à l'heure en fait le le
vrai problème est que aujourd'hui on
n'arrive plus à pouvoir exprimer des
oppositions de manière sereine sans
venir casser que ce soit les magasins
les forces de police ou autre on ne sait
plus manifester pacifiquement et
effectivement on en arrive à un moment
où on est toujours en opposition à tout
alors peut-être est-ce parce que les
corps intermédiaires ne sont pas assez
utilisés
en amont écouter et voilà il y a
peut-être des des causes à trouver
avant de d'aller comprendre
mais c'est bien vrai là je pense qu'on
manifeste tous les jours pour toutes les
mais ça c'est un vrai sujet de société
qui est beaucoup plus large que ça que
j'appelle la tyrannie des minorités
maintenant je suis dans un appartement
dans l'Aisne où il y a quelques projets
structurants qui non mais qui sont
voulus depuis longtemps par alors j'ai
pas les chiffres mais 95 % des gens
envoyés le doublement d'une route pour
améliorer la mobilité et vous avez
là-dedans 15 personnes qui vont avoir
autant de place que toutes les autres
autant dans les journaux autant sur les
réseaux sociaux extrêmement actifs et
qui des fois dérive et ça c'est
l'histoire de la force publique est-ce
qu'on vit dans un pays où c'est
l'immense majorité qui a raison ou c'est
quelques-uns qui brisent qui cassent et
qui que qui crient plus fort que les
autres qui ont raison ça va un vrai
sujet de société merci la question de
savoir s'il y a pas parfois des des
projets qui prennent un certain nombre
d'années à être construit ont-ils
toujours la même légitimité par la suite
donc elle est en vie on est dans un état
où il y a les règles il y en a beaucoup
quand vous passez toutes les toutes les
administratives toutes les tous les élus
sont d'accord et à la fin c'est 30
personnes qui vont dire tu fais pas
la parole la même chose que tout à
l'heure
et moi j'ai aucun problème à condamner
le fait que on massacre des vitrines à
Lyon le maire de Lyon l'a fait aussi et
les commerçants méritent pas de se faire
éclater leur vitrine parce qu'il y a des
manifestations contre la réforme des
retraites mais pourquoi est-ce que dans
une discussion sur le néonazisme au nord
des rimes à parler de la manif des
retraites et en général des oppositions
au gouvernement qui sont pas du tout
c'est parce qu'il y a il y a eu un coup
de poids de mesure dénoncé par la gauche
sur le traitement qui a été fait pour
lire les quatre lettres des vrais que à
la fois sur les questions écologiques en
général et aujourd'hui sur les questions
sociales cristallisées autour de la
réforme des retraites si vous voulez
quand vous avez et ça c'est pas les
écologistes qui sont élus etc ils
pourront rien si vous avez
un gouvernement des autorités publiques
l'État qui par ses décisions ne permet
pas de sauver le climat et la bitabilité
de la planète pour des jeunes qui
aujourd'hui se disent en fait dans 30
ans je sais pas si je vais pouvoir
respirer l'air et boire de l'eau il y a
un moment où la légitimité des décisions
qui sont prises fustent-elles légales
elle est compliquée à défendre et donc
il y a c'est qu'il a désobéissance
civile pour vous dans ces moments-là la
désobéissance civile bien sûr et c'est
pour ça que
c'est un une alerte importante le
gouvernement devrait se dire justement
nous devons répondre nous devons faire
des politiques publiques qui arrivent
finalement résoudre la crise climatique
réseau de la crise sociale parce que
sinon quel quel est le l'issue en fait
qu'on a si les lois qui sont adoptées
démocratiquement elles permettent pas de
garder la planète vivable allez on passe
à un autre sujet qui a marqué cette
séance de questions au gouvernement ce
sujet c'est celui de la fraude fiscale
question posée par Eric Bocquet qui a
l'air un petit peu déplacé la question
puisqu'il a lui parlait de l'évasion
fiscale un sujet qui lui est cher
écoutez nous l'autons avec intérêt
l'idée d'une Coop de la fiscalité et la
création d'un Conseil d'évaluation sans
doute une nouvelle mouture de
l'Observatoire imaginée par votre
illustre prédécesseur en septembre 2018
une instance qui malheureusement n'a
jamais vu le jour je crains monsieur le
ministre qui est un angle mort majeur
dans votre dispositif c'est celui des
paradis fiscaux
considérez-vous comme Bruxelles qui
n'existe pas de paradis fiscal au sein
de l'Union européenne vous le savez je
pense depuis six ans le gouvernement a
fait des choses sur ce sujet si les
multinationales sont désormais taxées à
un niveau minimal dans le monde c'est
grâce au gouvernement français c'est
grâce à la détermination de son
gouvernement de notre gouvernement qui a
porté ce sujet au niveau international
et nous allons continuer à le faire dans
le cadre de cette COP fiscale
une hausse de 25% des contrôles fiscaux
sur les gros patrimoines des contrôles
fiscaux tous les deux ans pour les 100
plus grandes capitalisations boursière
voilà notamment ce qu'a annoncé hier
Gabriel Attal Christine lavard parce que
ce sont des bonnes mesures parce que
c'est aussi de la communication
politique sur ce sujet j'ai compris que
c'était une partie du plan qui était
annoncé sachant qu'en plus ça
déclinaison va prendre des outils
législatifs divers il y en a une partie
qu'on va traiter très rapidement avec
finalement l'adaptation du code douanier
pour transposer une directive européenne
que d'autres mesures arriveront ensuite
en septembre moi je relève juste qu'il y
a tout un gros chantier qui a été mené
notamment par des travaux de la
commission des finances sur la fraude à
la TVA qui n'a absolument pas été abordé
par le ministre dans sa dans son
allocution donc peut-être est-ce pour
laisser le Sénat à porter sa fabrique
version à cette réforme à ce chantier
c'est une bonne chose vous le saluez
quand même le chantier lancé par Gabriel
Attal on entend aussi certains qui
disent bon
on n'a pas attendu ce chantier pour
lutter contre la fraude fiscale c'est
très largement une mise en conformité
avec ce que demande l'Europe et on nous
fait de la communication là-dessus une
partie c'est de la mise en conformité
puisque je vous le dis on va traduire
dans le droit français une directive
européenne très prochainement
après le sujet de la fraude c'est quand
même un sujet qui a été abordé par tous
les candidats à l'élection
présidentielle il y a un an donc ça veut
dire qu'il y a quand même encore des
choses à faire même si effectivement des
choses ont commencé déjà dans les dans
les dernières années à être faites
notamment sur la partie fraude fiscale
il faudra aussi après s'attaquer à la
fraude sociale il y a en parallèle un de
ces mesures qui visent plutôt les Ultra
riches et les entreprises qui fraudent
des mesures d'allègement de la pression
sur le petit contribuable sur le petit
patron on sent aussi là dessus il y a
l'idée de d'essayer de changer un peu
l'image d'Emmanuel Macron avec son
étiquette de président des riches pierre
jean-gardes
c'est pas c'est pas le sujet 1 lutter
contre la fraude évidemment oui ensuite
quels sont les sommes en jeu alors on va
attendre tout le monde vient avec ses
chiffres je suis toujours ébahi de gens
qui viennent parler de chiffres qui par
nature sont indéfinissable et
incurculables puis qui puisse qu'ils
échappent pour calculer pour calculer de
Bercy en tout cas ça pose le sujet de la
justice de l'effort et de la répartition
d'efforts entre les uns et les autres
dans le fonctionnement de la société et
donc c'est un sujet après les retraites
c'est un bon c'est un bon sujet
d'ailleurs je vais revenir au sujet aux
manifestations des retraites mais par un
autre un autre biais moi je suis un
département dans l'Aisne donc des
territoires ruraux on a vu on n'a jamais
vu autant de gens dans les villes
moyennes manifester alors il y avait
ceux qui étaient vous voyez le côté le
grand capital etc mais il y avait plein
d'autres c'était l'autre versant j'ai vu
des gens manifester que j'avais jamais
vu eux c'était sur le thème
bah moi on me demande de faire deux ans
plus mais je vais les faire comme
d'habitude je vais faire l'effort et par
contre quelques maisons de chez moi il y
a quelqu'un qui est en capacité de
travailler qui ne travaille pas et lui
on lui demande aucun effort et ça j'en
peux plus et ça c'est le sujet des
classes moyennes et si je résumais ça
dans une formule qui choquera peut-être
en France si vous êtes très riche ou
très pauvre
l'état s'occupe de vous enfin vous voilà
et tout ce qui est au milieu les classes
moyennes c'est ce sont parlons de ce
qu'on s'occupe trop peu il est là le
malaise de la société c'est que les gens
qui sont entre les deux qui travaillent
qui financent tous les dispositifs
sociaux qui pour tout le monde mais ils
sont pas ces récompensés
qui échappent à l'impôt les entreprises
les grands contribuables et des petits
contribuer aussi d'ailleurs puissent
participer au financement de la
collectivité
à ce plan donc annoncer hier et beaucoup
de communication à part Gabriel Attal
d'abord juste sur si vous êtes très
pauvre très riche les tests s'occupe de
vous oui alors il y a juste une
situation avec elle s'est méritée puis
vous êtes très pauvre et puis il y a une
situation dans laquelle ça l'est pas
donc c'est quand même pas la même chose
et le même niveau de problème vous
comprenez le mot que je voulais dire
c'est que ces deux catégories il y a
beaucoup de plan pour eux il y a
beaucoup de doigts pour eux par contre
entre les deux il y en a beaucoup moins
voilà après c'est
heureusement que on vient plus en aide
aux gens qui ont le plus besoin enfin
c'est un peu la baisse du contrat social
c'était dans laquelle on vit
sur le plan vous l'avez dit c'est de la
mise en conformité principalement avec
le droit européen
voilà enfin donc c'est un plan de
communication autour des avancées en
matière de de
lutte contre l'évasion fiscale et la
force fiscale notamment la fois de la
TVA au niveau européen sans dire que ça
vient du niveau européen voilà il y a
notre angle mort qui a été soulevé
d'ailleurs par Éric Bocquet tout à
l'heure c'est celui à vous vous
souleviez l'angle de la fraude sociale
lui se lever celui de l'évasion fiscale
un sujet sur lesquels il a beaucoup
travaillé il a parlé de de l'Open luxe
de 55000 sociétés offshore de 6500
milliards d'actifs parce que on
s'attaque on ne s'attaque pas encore
cette fois-ci à ce à cette manne
financière alors on s'y attaque très mal
au niveau européen effectivement c'est
vrai il y a des paradis fiscaux au sein
de l'Union européenne d'ailleurs des
États qui sont pas perçus comme ça comme
la France l'Allemagne sont des paradis
fiscaux à certains égards pas surtout
mais à certains égards mais le
Luxembourg l'Irlande ont des des
politiques fiscales qui s'apparentent à
des paradis fiscaux certains égards
les Pays-Bas qui sont d'ailleurs qui en
fait vide les caisses d'État qui ont
besoin de ces recettes pour faire des
politiques publiques et qui sont parfois
ceux les états au niveau européen qui
sont les plus réticents à investir et à
faire des politiques publiques de
redistribution des richesses alors
qu'ils ont dans leur caisse une partie
des richesses qui est un grand problème
effectivement pourquoi je suis désolé
d'être un peu technique et un des gros
problèmes qu'on a avec ça c'est que les
questions fiscales au niveau européen
c'est l'unanimité et ça c'est un énorme
problème parce qu'en fait si vous voulez
faire des politiques fiscales au niveau
européen un moment donné vous pouvez pas
vous mettre dans une situation où un
état qui n'a pas intérêt est-ce que vous
fassiez quelque chose peut seul tout
empêcher au niveau européen et donc oui
c'est un énorme chantier un chantier
à mettre en place mettre la fin c'est
unanimité nécessaire on peut également
et faire des politiques de
redistribution des richesses les
politiques fiscales au niveau européen
parce que c'est une question au fond de
contrat social européen cette affaire
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Christine
lavard de est-ce que et bien avec ce
plan il y a quand même beaucoup beaucoup
de choses qui manquent on le voit c'est
bien on recherche effectivement de
l'argent il y a encore bien des choses à
faire et notamment au niveau de
l'évasion fiscale il y a bien des choses
à faire encore et quand on vous parlait
tout à l'heure des mesures on va dire
plus douce finalement pour les chefs
d'entreprise les entreprises en fait
c'est des choses qui existent déjà parce
qu'on a passé une loi justement sur le
droit à l'erreur qui en fait lui en dire
déjà un petit peu la même chose
c'est-à-dire que la personne qui se
trompe en
ignorant la loi même si personne n'est
censé l'ignorer mais pas vraiment elle
sera de toute façon pas pénaliser pour
autant donc on dit pas quelque chose de
très différent avec les mesures qui ont
été annoncées donc effectivement il y a
beaucoup de communication après sur des
avancées vraiment concrètes il y a du
travail à faire et nous notamment on le
fera pour la partie qui nous concerne
dans le prochain projet loi de finance
alors il nous reste 5 minutes dans cette
émission et je voudrais quand même que
l'on les consacre et bien à cette
cérémonie de commémoration de
l'esclavage qui se tient actuellement
dans le jardin du Luxembourg où vous
voyez et bien notamment Elisabeth bandel
la première ministre qui préside cette
cérémonie voyait aussi Christiane
Taubira qui a été à l'origine de
l'instauration de cette commémoration
vous voyez également Jean-Marc Ayrault
le président la présidente de
l'Assemblée nationale Yale brune
c'est jeune qui sont issus et de
l'hexagone et de l'outre-mer et parmi
lesquels comptes des lauréats du
concours national de la flamme de
l'égalité sur la mémoire de l'esclavage
politique cette commémoration de
l'esclavage on se rappelle par exemple
début du quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron
il y avait et François Hollande et
Emmanuel Macron qui était présent il y
avait des discours du président de la
République c'est plus du tout le cas
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que ça vous
inspire cette cette commémoration un
petit peu à minima quand même bon à
titre personnel j'ai pas j'ai pas vécu
j'ai pas vécu les précédentes
commémorations bah écoutez c'est un
moment d'histoire c'est un moment pour
se souvenir et dans ces moments-là ce
qui est important c'est que ce soit des
moments de rassemblement et de concorde
c'est plutôt ce que j'observe alors
peut-être qu'il y a moins de monde que
les autres années et que les choses sont
réparés dans les dans les années qui
viennent mais c'est important tout de
même de faire ces
commémorations de l'esclavage qu'elle
puisse perdurer on rappelle que cela a
été instauré par Jacques Chirac et que
depuis c'est quand même un moment qui
continue d'être très important
aujourd'hui il y a aussi et bien toute
une commémoration qui est consacrée à
tout ça l'ouverture à ancien esclave
combattant de la liberté c'est le 2e
anniversaire de sa mort
évidemment c'est important évidemment je
partage le fait que ça doit être des
moments de d'union il y a un sujet dans
la loi Taubira qui avait été à l'époque
promu puis retiré et qu'on a toujours
pas réglé en France c'est la question
des réparations il y avait eu dans la
première mouture l'idée de d'avoir un
comité qui réfléchirait aux conditions
d'ananas
c'est quelque chose qui a été fait dans
d'autres pays dans le monde et la France
arrive pas à passer à passer à cette
étape ni même à y réfléchir de façon
sereine et moi j'aimerais bien qu'on
trouve que ça veut dire ça reflète un
rapport compliqué à notre histoire
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour vous
oui bien sûr ça reflète un rapport
compliqué à la responsabilité face à
certains événements historiques et puis
ce que ça implique parce que
réparer c'est au fond l'étape d'après
une fois qu'on a reconnu un préjudice
et bien il vaut mieux ne pas juste
regarder le préjudice et dire ah bah oui
il existe il y a une étape qui vient
normalement après qui est le fait de le
réparer alors évidemment
la forme que ça doit prendre elle est à
discuter aujourd'hui mais les
conséquences de l'esclavage elles
existent toujours dans le monde les
inégalités
Nord-Sud et tout ça c'est des choses qui
qui c'est pas un événement qui isolé qui
a ensuite disparu et il a eu des impacts
il continue d'en avoir et donc moi
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrive en tout cas
on débattre de façon sereine et à poser
ces questions au moins se les poser j'ai
pas toutes les réponses je sais pas
comment on doit faire mais je pense
qu'on n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout on
n'est pas allé jusqu'au bout Christine
Navarre sur cette question cette
question de la réparation nous dit des
amis vos gel voilà est-ce que les
commémorations aujourd'hui suffisent en
tout cas ce qui est certain c'est que
cette question de l'esclavage
effectivement on en parle le 10 mai les
gens qui ont voulu aller au jardin du
Luxembourg aujourd'hui ont vu qu'on
organise une cérémonie peut-être que
certains quand ils voient le monument
avec les chaînes brisées savent à quoi
fait référence ce monument mais en fait
effectivement au-delà de ça il faut
aussi nous continuer à éduquer à
éveiller nos jeunes générations
effectivement on va plus connaître la
traite des esclaves en France mais comme
le disait mais la niveau gel il faut se
poser des questions sur la manière dont
sont fabriqués nos vêtements nos
chaussures dans des pays où les droits
des enfants et les droits des personnes
humaines ne sont peut-être pas
aujourd'hui que ceux qui sont
effectivement dans l'Union dans le sein
de l'espace européen et donc c'est des
questions sur lesquelles on doit
toujours être très sensible très
vigilant et si cette journée pouvait
effectivement permettre d'éveiller tout
le monde sur ce qui est l'esclavage
moderne aujourd'hui c'est vraiment
important et bien merci merci beaucoup à
tous les trois d'avoir participé à ce
débrief des questions au gouvernement
tandis que l'on voit et bien les images
du chanteur James Germain qui est en
train de chanter devant et bien
notamment Elisabeth Borge
Pivet pour cette commémoration de
l'abolition de l'esclavage tout de suite
et bien on se retrouve dans l'émission
avoir 20 ans une émission consacrée à la
défiance envers les sciences et
notamment le complotisme une émission
consacrée à la jeunesse sur Public Sénat
très bonne fête des programmes sur
Public Sénat
[Musique]